[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
all right what's going on around
talk to me right quick let's make sure
the levels is good mexican zoidberg
oh my man from twitch all right all
right logo or the brain logo with the
fo-fo
noise then grand risings death mobile
what's up dizzy what's going on
what's going on squirrely i see you
cheating you cheating on him with that
uh
arc that's cool go talk to your boy
that's dizzy
what's going on let me know how the
levels is man let me know i love this no
vaseline the legend
finish up that medium i see you yeah i'm
saying
talk to me right quick chat let's see
what's going on atticus xs is here
thank you so motivate my man always
making sure i'm on point
good to see you brother i hope
everything is good with you you know
what i'm saying
every area stand up selfish gamer what's
up
no bad i see you so yeah we gonna get
guys up in here to feel
running a little snow myself so uh
trying to get warmed up
it's dizzy that's that cheat to pick the
game up with more content
listen man we're not going to do this
this morning last time i checked your uh
most games played on xbox your position
was not higher than destiny sir
[Music]
not even close make sure vin diesel
drops the back pixel bit g what up
what's going on i salute the uh salute
to squirrels
all right y'all the king and everybody
will be arriving soon i'm gonna try to
get
woken up and speak to attic get gas up
in here
and have some fun so i'll see y'all
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um
you know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i
am uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arcing up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to started
regardless back we was messaging people
on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
a proclamation
[Music]
if i can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that
option you're gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's the
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though
i know it's my destiny words incognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that you can't
even still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible wasn't it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
fortunate but whatever you want to do
then it's doable if you got work on a
sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle
[Music]
on a lord's day
[Music]
welcome to the iron laws podcast and the
lords of gaming.net
episode number 194 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table of the lord's date
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got microsoft's earnings call
the medium impressions and bleeding edge
shutdown to discuss
so we gonna get right into it i want to
introduce a lord whose enthusiasm and
passion for gaming
truly resonates within a highly
respectable multimedia platform
whether it's hosting the who's who
within our games industry or just having
some fun
with our fellow content creators
introducing the co-owner of the news
aggregation platform
gameondaily.com and the host
of the go live podcast on youtube
the lord forever swimming in the source
especially rocking that ilp snapback
on live stream live from london
and making his debut into the realm of
the lords
my man lord gaze of game on daily how
you doing sir
oh my god i'm getting sick bro you need
to get an award for that
announcement geez that's the best
introduction i'll ever get in my life
much appreciated brothers speak for
yourself we ain't never got oh my god
brother you're a lord i'm gonna need to
leave and then come
back as a different entity entirely and
then i'll get it man
you know what i'm gonna be addict with
the c for this
you gotta say it is
what up brother how you doing man oh man
i'm just absolutely honored to be
uh to be here man thank you so much for
the invite
just yeah i can't wait to get into the
topics you guys are
thank you i love you guys much love
wrapping all your matches
i'll be feeling i'll be like yeah i just
love right there man i saw yours i was
like yo you got the swagger that's fire
if i can get one of those banners behind
king david i would get that
[Laughter]
[Music]
we got i think we got some super chat
before we roll in yeah we got to start
off with cedric
h's 20 super chat let's go fire you
already know
brother you already know we got cat
daddy with the five dollar super chat
inferiority is
is the life of all other podcasts intros
compared to ilp
salute he always give it up man
salute the cat and a little cat because
i see you out there man
a lot of single-player games and bursts
that's what i notice you do now
there's another one we got we got no
more yeah
we got michael aka best stocks finest
with the five dollar super chat
god morning lords and king of almighty
xbox king david what's good man god
bless to you and let's keep it xbox on
god and never
but i'm gonna tell you right now xbox
stand up
he ready he's ready we got mexican
zoidberg with the two dollars in the
chat ask him which mass effect is the
best
oh
we got the four horsemen of gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table even though attic get mad at
his intro
my co-host with the colt most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord definitely in his own world and the
how
of the young wolf my man lord addict how
are we doing sir
doing pretty good you know i might be
the lord of my own world but you know
what i else i'm the lord of i'm the lord
of that
eyes of tomorrow that no one else
we plan to do this to you anyway
we planned to come on stream we this was
all planned
wow so y'all both pulled up with the new
dude
i mean you raided with us how many times
this week um this week no i have not
raised exactly
[Laughter]
tomorrow you know what it it it's like
the lottery kick hog you got to be in it
it's a winner
this one week and dudes pulling up
acting that's three shots at the title
baby three shots
i hit it with my first shot ah so a
little exotic little exotic ball was
there waiting for you
yo i was in that raid shout out to
megatron because the megatron hair
we was in that rage attic no for
i don't know how many hours at the boss
in megatron we definitely gonna
you i don't care what you're doing
megatron anytime you see me on jump in
my game because
we're going we're gonna coach you up i
heard y'all gotta throw my man in the
dojo like what's going on
boy oh boy boy oh boy you ever see a
dude
where his form is off his form is off
everything wasn't right you know what's
crazy king i i was using that isaac
tomorrow on gambit x cognito that
was terrible
they had like 40 moats about to deliver
it i shot
i didn't even aim i was i went like i
just went and then
shot it and then all i know is i died
right here
double double double he's like you
killed them all guardian
savage racist listen excuse me
save me that day attic went to work
and was playing on his phone
from work oh yeah yes on wi-fi you're
savage
in the raid if x-cloud ain't that ish
i don't know what you on but my man came
in
and he saved me from the bushes because
i was about to die
i was in my house look at y'all in the
chat i can try to chat laughing
i don't care and addy can do no wrong to
me
he was playing with us he left he was on
his console
this is the greatest thing in the world
i'm gonna tell you all right now if
y'all don't know he was on his console
say yo i gotta go to work and we was
like dad we're gonna lose attic
attic went to work got to his
destination
jumped in our chat on his phone yes
and said let me get in there because
some dude had to go we had a quitter on
our team shout out to hawaiian ooh
oh damn
and then attic saved the day he
is the shining knight he's the he's the
white knight in shining armor
he's my man yeah he's talking too much
about the eyes at the bar but anyway
alex uh what else
and you know i've been shooting the eyes
of tomorrow and gams that have been
shooting the eyes in tomorrow and the
strikes
what else have you been playing besides
destiny and shooting the eyes of
tomorrow
i played a little bit of medium but
obviously we'll get into that hair
momentarily
no doubt no doubt and of course we have
our most technical gaming lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patriarch of the iron
bank
maybe one more week away from the camera
my man lord sovereign how we doing
that is correct one more week away from
the camera i apologize to everybody
people asking in the chat
have access to my primary setup right
now
or my console so just one more week and
i'll be back to normal so
the truth sovereign has a zit on his
nose
no i i can't be any i cannot be on
camera with
anything less than anything listen man
you're messing up messing up the female
demographic the numbers are down
and we need my bears to give back rico
suave
we need this no no
we need to get the face job done he
gonna be back yeah i'll be back i'll be
back
with your plagues actually yes i don't
have access to my console so i haven't
played hitman yet but
i do have i do have my laptop so
uh i played the medium on there okay so
i didn't get it doing that sir um it's
called game pass
i don't know a little servers a little
service that you might know about
wait wait wait wait so wait wait time
out i'm confused here
you were quarantined off with no
access to your console but you were
still
able to partake this wondrous adventure
that that i was sir that i was this is
amazing
my laptop isn't banging like that so i
wasn't you know ray tracing it up but uh
i was good though i was good i was good
it was good i was good
yeah so another game passed selection
where you wouldn't believe it king okay
oh cyber shadow oh yes old school
2d goodness that has once again showed
me that i am trash at these games i'm
horrible at these games but uh yeah
cyber shadow
in game pass right now fantastic 2d sky
side scroller it is um difficult
in the vein of old school ninja gaiden
was published by yacht club games i
don't
recall the actual developer shout out to
the king and match
right now yeah right now they're gonna
get thrown down
because i know i want to give a shout
out to kaibatsu your brother
yes who was he he knew about the game
before and got the packs oh yeah
interview to go do it um and i think me
and you went to go do it and then the
following year kaiba 2 was there
yeah but those the developer didn't have
any representation there
nope the person that they had watching
the booth to talk about the game
was the most dismissive individual that
i've ever encountered
and i was like i'm i'm giving you a look
and she's like
yeah well you know we're not here for
that you know i was like wow the game
looks really good
and i said you know what we're going to
capture your footage we're going to do
this without you
and you know shout out to the game
actually is inside game pass and it
looks really good but yes you know
um that was it was horrible i remember
that
yeah now they dad do you remember when
we went to um
uh play nyc yeah as well
and and the reception was different yeah
the reception was different shout out to
macho in the chat in the chat right now
he said when
we said i think that game he said he got
exposed at pax because he kept dying he
quit the devil
yeah i mean this is this is this is like
for attic for kaibatsu hardcore
hardcore i dude i got to the second
level
and i'm like i'm doing i'm good at these
games but i hadn't i need more time i'm
not like
savant like these games so you're not
good with these games
precisely like you got to be savant like
in these games
um yeah man unless i hear w's it's l's
nah nah
it oh it is an l don't get me wrong it's
an l i'll take the l gladly but it's a l
no doubt so that's
i'm surprised you didn't get that hit
man i want to talk to you about that
yeah
i mean i have it on my console already i
just i don't want to buy it again
on the pc so wait you got to buy it like
oh because it's not a game package
yeah hello so we got the board game
renegade with the 5 super chat
so many needs are going to get to be
scraped and dislocated after today's
xbox
earnings topic also sea of thieves
season one in medium of fire salute
game pass then we have the living flame
with the five dollar super chat good
morning lawrence the next generation has
officially begun with the medium because
demon's soul still doesn't care oh
wow phil is making back wow
don't count if you spitting verses over
something that was already written
my god we don't care about no old
playstation 3 games throw it in the
bushes
squarely damn with the two dollar super
chat that bump
on stops lips got some yo yo
we putting out people problems
that is
i'm gonna need you to fix those things
around the uh the pictures this is
a little little bit of area above it man
you guys think that's bothering me yes
yes yes
and we got anthony boyd with the father
super chat who out here with those tcl
tvs throw them in the bushes
it's starting early today king early
forever
[Music]
i like my games like i like my steak
medium hit that like button and don't
forget about the one in the spiritual
world
yeah now we caught up yeah we're caught
up and
of course we have the incredible hulk of
the earnings call
the prophet of xbox king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
lord king the beloved one how are we
doing sir
boy you heard that music when i was
coming in i said
put your money with your mouth
you know what king probably did see
those stairs to the left man he probably
did that dance going yeah
he was shitty today mario was dancing
before i came in he said are you already
boss
that's what i am mario you know what
today is
first of all i want to give a shout out
to dcx we had the live unboxing
saturdays was successful
i saw megatron in the chat stitch is
always there i also want to give a shout
out to stitch for helping with the raid
the other day getting us through that
um listen iron lords podcast clan is the
best clan
you can reach out back for dead also
helped out and we got that done with uh
people that are learning to raid so we
are
uh a teaching uh podcast um clan
and we grow together we teach we get
past stuff
but um i had a breakage yesterday in in
my stature
joint it's live unboxing it's high risk
high reward or also
you can fail so um but the replacement
body
is uh in the works uh or or
it's as a cash compensation situation
and i go get a fix from the statue
doctor
it is what it is um but what i've been
playing this week
let me just get the game pass a little
go up right in right now
i know it's coming so let's go oh god
what was it game pass this week sir do
you feel it
do you do you feel it do you smell
what game pass is cooking oh it's medium
rare
whoa you know i told you dude
blooper team you should have launched
the same day cyberpunk launch
the hell was cyberpunk damn today what's
cyberpunk
dizzy agrees with you it didn't even
come out you know but
but the medium is here and um
of course it has a little technical
issues here and there we're gonna get
into that into that
um but i'm gonna tell you right now
because i don't you know what we talk
about it later but uh medium is here
no doubt um also uh um cyber shadow
cyber shadow is here um the games to
play this weekend
madden is the slickest uh company in the
world
you got the super bowl getting ready to
pop off everybody got football frenzy
and there's no football this weekend so
they give you madden this weekend to get
your [ __ ]
yo this that was genius
because i downloaded it my son
downloaded it he's playing it
so i i think that was a stroke of genius
on and i hope it's available on
playstation i wouldn't know because you
know if a tree falls in the forest
right there to hear it nobody knows but
i'm just saying you know over here on
the xbox
over there on your side on your side you
know what's going on
yo everybody know about that madden over
here though
if y'all got fomo sorry for you they all
give it a gate to your defense they are
giving like some type of game pass
promotion if you play like an online
game because i was like oh all i gotta
do is play an online game i get 100
points
and the points add up just by playing
game pass games oh yeah for sure those
points
they give you a thousand every month if
you get a certain amount of uh
achievements yeah game pass score i got
a 25 microsoft rewards
just by playing for like two three weeks
it's crazy megatron told me he has
enough points this was
this is highly disgusting he has enough
points
to purchase a whole pc table
savage that's what i said i said oh i
don't have connections like that
i said i don't know what you're doing
it's just if you cop
everything digital you you you're
collecting points for years
you know how like we uh you know
obviously iop we always
invest back we always get codes to give
away so
i noticed that since i'm buying those
with my account what
oh you're speaking about oh that's right
yes yes
remember we got something special yeah
yeah yeah all right okay don't forget
that we got don't forget the shout out
when you do but that's been it sir uh
yeah that's been it it's been high
destiny eyes of tomorrow situation
it's been a crazy roller coaster ride
with the medium that we're going to get
into
um and it's been you know little bits in
here
the greatest thing you know my son and i
game and you know he he's he's 10 now
and he he's upstairs and you know i'm
downstairs
and we're playing you know games
together so
and you know he it's out of control i
never imagined anything like this and
stuff like that so
you know from a from a dad perspective
so you know shout out to cat daddy fat
sex
and um when your little one gets to the
age that you could actually gain
you're gonna reflect and have this wild
smile for no reason
it's a wild smile wow
with the sons you already know sons and
daughters son
of daughters yeah we've got some sort of
chat that i roll in
uh we got element appeal with the five
dollar super chat medium is out
ssd is out what is sony releasing return
and their own ssd again
night like this wait a second did they
ever release the expansion memory are
they still running with the same old
crusty memory that they got oh my god
yeah i don't i don't know if the
expansion they know they're
there's still no there's still so hard
to fix that
there's no hard drive that can take the
power of the ps5 right
oh man they're still in the bushes with
that same old crusty memory
oh that's true and i i i'm not even
thinking about attaching an external to
that
like yeah i don't know because it's
unstable that's something i'm not
doing something over there yeah for sure
like it's one of those things like
i don't know either they don't help you
moving on from king's messiness so
we have the living flame with the two
thousand king came down the stairs like
arthur fleck
shout out to the hood shout out to the
bx staircase that's the vx staircase
we actually know about that staircase we
live yes yeah yeah oh yeah we've been on
that
joker and we got lord of roughness
what's going on praise be the game pass
18 million subscribers without halo
infinite with bethesda yet
to sign off and xcloud still in beta i'm
sorry sir we rounding that number up
that's 20 million
it said 18 million plus you know how
king does that
we don't have the king's mafia yo
imagine yeah how do you went on to the
nearest
million
king i want to know your logic behind
raising it 1.5 million go
okay no when they gave you the
information
it was uh oh two days later
gonna get in his michael pack the bag
later
oh we caught up yeah we're good we're
good all right oh my god you're so messy
today
hey yeah definitely duh and of course we
have the gaming hinger himself without
isaac tomorrow lord cognito just regular
day in the hood for me
young legend see me grace a little see
me man he pulls up yo see me if you went
here because you said you lurk a lot of
times you always give a shout out man i
want to shout you out
good dude in the community yeah that was
what's up he's killing it man it's both
super
talented the kid could do everything
have some great conversations check that
out if you want your destiny fix back
for dead i see you up in there a lot of
guys
up in here and girls i see up in last
word and i appreciate it so that's love
um yeah other than that obviously the
medium you know we will talk about that
later on
what else i've been doing um gears
tactics like crazy i'm back addicted i
just can't stop
i still you know i'm going down this
sword y'all gears tactics
outside of high busters because high
busters is you know being you know i'm
going to disrespect
but as far as cinematics in a video game
not in touch against tactics man shout
out to splash dash shout out to joseph
i don't know you haven't thrown it on
your series x sir they're throwing out
seriously oh my god
what beats them blair
those cut seeds are pretty epic too yeah
i'm telling you man throw that yo
let me ask you a question has anybody
tried that game since they had a series
yeah i did and it's still broken on
concerts also the freeway
look
they didn't go back to it uh obviously
because the frame rate is still
folded mm-hmm i don't play i played it
on pc and it's yeah it runs beautifully
but
ugh okay yeah no i just i i couldn't get
past the frame rate i told people
yeah you should give me a shout out to
see what's going on but yeah for me i
said i gotta continue to praise through
he said now
so i got i gotta continue to praise gets
tactics man splash damage
coalition the stuff they added for
series x then they're using us vrs tech
shout out to mods gaming who uh put us
on on launch gaming.net right quick
gotta shout the whole team
you know what i'm saying but um yeah man
the tech that they it's it's phenomenal
is it watching is it cold cold um i
monster they was rocking the hive
busters was getting it going so that was
fun man but
yeah i would of course hit man three and
you're cool my new thing is um quick
resume
sort of quick resume rotation right now
like i said yakuza kids tactics
hitman you know say oh medium we got
problems we got issues because you're
not in quick resume sir
yes mine is mine's been quick result did
y'all scream well okay
i turned off quick resume because it's
still not it it
it has folded my my gaming a few times i
just turned it off
well okay i don't know about them jason
ronald but i got the good experience
i was i was really going to praise them
right there because what happened
yesterday is
they were getting the raid team ready
and i had the headset on so i mute them
yeah
because i'm playing the medium and then
they had the ray team ready and they
sent the invite out
and i jumped out did my destiny and then
after that was finished jumped out from
them and quick resume exactly where i
was
doing exactly what i was getting quicker
is amazing it works
it's a game changer i'm getting stuff
done anyway enough about that
a lot of shows going on so now that
we've got into what the lords have been
playing we got to focus on the man of
the hour here
lord gaz his video game system history
his journey into content creation of
course what led him to be
becoming the co-founder with lord asa of
the outstanding news aggregate game only
dot
com so lord guys let's start from the
very beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had what
got you to gaming
um yeah the first ever console i had was
i think we called it the second mega
drive i think you had
genesis that was it
more combat one was my first ever game
that i purchased
yeah so yeah that was a good start to it
uh
it was like a three-in-one kind of game
so it had something called sunset riders
i don't know who
if anyone remembers that oh yeah for
sure
that was sick and some aliens game but
yeah it was more combat was my first
ever game and i've always loved that
maybe i'm just biased because of them
growing up
yeah that was it i was that's i was laid
eyes on the concert when i was
i was uh seriously i just really mean
chat is putting me off because oh god
it's guys i'm out yeah yeah it will be
like they
will be a sticker they're like oh let's
get me out of here dodge told me that i
got to keep you on your best behavior
so a lot of the chat but wait a minute
so so not the 38's like
you got bottled there was no resistance
from the family like that was a big
deal remember that was the ratings thing
it was the genesis one had blood in it
like there was you was able to pick that
up no problem arms and pops was letting
this rock
uh man my parents are asian so if
there's anything sexual that's not
allowed but
any kind of violence
at the age of four they let them play
with knives
any other standouts for you on that
genesis era that glorious sega
mega drive man it's funny because it
goes to show
the shortcomings in my intellectual
capacity because i remember
being involved in console wars before my
my
balls had actually dropped so it and it
all started with my neighbor having a
nintendo that i didn't have
so yeah the super nintendo and i had the
mega drive and i just turned into a full
sonic fan
so sonic and mario was this massive
thing so i'll always say
i lost the biggest fanboy war because
you know
what happened to sonic compared to what
happened to mario
that's great that's why you said that
man because it was the genesis the edius
jetty s
genesis suspended that that was that was
contentious for its time right it was
crazy the question i got for you because
i'm assuming that i was also using the
uk at that time was that for
us we had there was a whole marketing
behind it it was like genesis does
you can't do this on intel it was a
whole thing now
because it was mega drive over there did
they do any type of marketing poking fun
at nintendo the way they did in the
states
me no so when i i didn't actually live
in the uk
i was actually born in pakistan so i was
actually
so i was brought up there so get adverts
for games
you're just praying for electricity
people have no advertising campaigns man
it was just
even my first ever game that i bought
typically
in pakistan
so you know growing up there you
you thought that is called a poly
station i don't think that's the right
yo
like it was that hard to get stuff to
get and stuff but guys guys i was gonna
say
that you're gonna say no no it's the
thing the difficulty in getting those
things a lot of those aftermarket
essentially bootleg consoles be
really got gained traction in a lot of
countries where
it was very difficult to get the primary
consoles or they
they actually weren't selling them
legally and importing them would be
crazy like if
you look at the brazilian market the
brazilian market is flooded
with all of these type of consoles in
addition to you know genera like two
three old generation consoles because
it's just the price of getting it over
there and buying it over there is so
high
that people are usually behind to it to
two generations it actually sucks
you know yeah it's really crazy you know
because there's a whole black market
thing but
yeah to this point where he had the
cartridges that had like 101
you know and stuff like that um it
started taking off hair
because over there where you were were
it was super successful
yeah you know so in in markets like
china
and um in uh you know europe and stuff
like that
and and arab nations those those
cartridges that had all those games on
it was a way
for gaming to exist in these little
markets where they couldn't sell
you know two or three you know games or
whatever so you get that one cartridge
for whatever the price was
and you actually partake some of the
games didn't work but some of them games
did work and
i mean it's shout out to you for saying
you know for even being real enough
that's real about it yeah
electricity he said we wasn't even
worried about you know the marketing
deal we was worried about that
who got that generator popping plug that
kind of fact
generator man that thing was the
lifesaver if you had a generator you
were you were rich we didn't have a
generator
so i would go down to my so i was forced
to go to my friend's house we had to
generate and he had a bloody nintendo
did you ever bring your console with you
to his house
we live right next to you you're right
okay we're just walking he was
funnily enough he was an american back
this was before pre-911
we weren't seen as people who
spontaneously come bust all the time so
this is a massive massive difference
expat community there so there were
americans um
they were chilling all the time oh yeah
it was really cool very different time
and it was really cool and that's when
forced electricity outages forced me to
go play nintendo
[Laughter]
a lot of realness you know i've never
heard stories from from pakistan and
just
hearing how people were doing these
things to gain and to
get into their passion it's crazy
because you think of you think about our
situations growing up right and we we
were lucky that i mean
we didn't grow up rich poor we're kind
of in the middle right
and think for yourself i was dead
all right i mean like i said there was a
range of situations
i understand what you're saying yeah you
know i get it i get it
and and if you think about it like in
comparison to what a lot of people's
situations
are in different parts of the world even
in where you live like
we had it good and sometimes you think
about this stuff and you talk about this
stuff and it really is first world
problem yeah
cause i remember we have mods i remember
moms were telling us poland
how it was stuff yeah salute to gas man
he had to go to the hitman
the mafia i had to go to play the
like this little kid let's give him an
xbox
but first he must uh complete this
mission
salute to balance anyway moving on
so they're from genesis like did you
were you still able to continue gaming
on all the platforms like what was your
progression
as you got older so as a gold i moved to
the uk when i was 13.
but as i was moving the playstation came
out
and with the advent of discs came
lots of piracy babies i'm not promoting
piracy
he said yes we are yes we are yeah your
console can get hacked that's on youtube
so you can't tell me being impacted on
that i'm not gonna play pirates
games that was the only choice we had i
mean we didn't make that distinction
though we didn't even call them pirated
games but
what's funny is things turned because
before with the cartridges
we would pay a premium for the
cartridges because they they
yeah but with the discs came out then
you'd see
then you'd see like the expats you see
and honestly true story happen all the
time
we we used to go to the shop so he's
like these are like crazy
stalls basically man there's just
madness and like karachi
and you'd see like a white couple there
and they're like oh my god
they're like new on holiday and we're
paying
hundred rupees for two games they're
paying 2 000 rupees for one game
thinking they're getting the deal of
their lifestyle
i just the same game just that you did
we're just sitting there laughing
is that tourist tax you know that
eyes lit up they're like oh i remember
this german couple there they're like
oh yeah let's go buy them dashing out
money and the guys
the shopkeeper just looked at me so
we're
okay cool give me one second we have
viper
xt with the five dollar super chat i
don't usually like these beyond two
souls heavy rain type games but the
medium is hitting every note for me
over halfway in and loving it so far
what they need to stop saying like
beyond two no let's go for the crown
let's go for the king
which is silent hill stop stop don't
compare it to anything other
than the top of the top it's it's silent
hill compare it to that
we're going for the top because silent
hill has been not seen so the king is
dead
so oh my god moving on with the super
chest yeah we got one away dragon tv
chat what's good lord shout out to the
chat always lit thank you brother
no it's a little one away yeah
gaming times patrick with the five
dollar super chat excited for the show
tell king leave my floyd tv alone my my
one from the back is coming next week
that's what i'm talking about he's
upgrading he's upgrading yeah see
regardless of what you realize you're
error in your way
hold on we got booming double barrel
game and i see those videos brother
you know what i'm saying i see you out
here moving and shaking it's working but
anyway your boat's definitely working
it's a little ball man but yeah like you
say so you would transition
back you see that the price differential
you're saying games
you're now getting that playstation
popping the the discs are live
you did you have that cd folder of all
those those different
ones so you know it you know i know i
know about that life so
i've introduced us so so question uh
what what sort of a modifications did
your console have did you have the uh
the eraser with the paper clip or did
you uh did you have like a hard
modification
i had a hard modification we're not
doing no
razor little that i remember those
things people talking about
we had the real technicians on site
listen we can't ignore it it was a big
scene
during those times so they're from any
standout that was the real game pass
that was getting before it started i'm
gonna tell you right now i think that's
where the genesis of it happened
it happened from individuals that was
that folder because i have folders on
top of folders
yeah what just sat there was like how
can we make this digital list
were doing it before discs because
like king said he went down to elizabeth
street or canal street
and they had they had just come out with
this machine that looked like it looked
like a 3d old it was like a big
big thing and so we went in right and i
i don't understand the terminology yet
right so i'm asking the guy that i'm
like
oh so this thing plays copied games he
said no no
backup oh yeah oh so you could copy a
game said no no no no
he thought i was a cop
if you own the game you can back it up
he had to make sure he was he wasn't he
was ready to kick me out of the store
because i wasn't getting it and king was
looking at me like yo you have to use
the terminology man
what was funny is when he realized that
oh he's with the black guy
okay they don't have
[Laughter]
luke it was definitely definitely a big
time scene what's going on with the
place you know what the attic is going
crazy i think it's going crazy i don't
know what he doing
but all doing bad things to you yeah he
out of control anyway so like i said so
any standouts during the um playstation
ever like
any standouts do you remember from those
games yeah man um
i think that was probably my favorite
generation because
the sheer volume of games i could play
which is why i'm excited for game plus
because then it kind of breaks that
barrier down again
it really does because games are
expensive man
yeah 70 dollars that's that's nuts
absolutely that's a little
then things changed because for some
reason games were available
in pakistan that weren't available
elsewhere so yeah
yeah it's pretty crazy can you remember
yeah i want to say can you any standards
anything you remember from pakistan that
um
that they had that you that wasn't
available when you were uk yeah
a very very good question and i remember
so so then i moved obviously to the uk
and um you buy the you know gaming
magazines and
more uh the first 3d mortal kombat game
i forgot the name of it now which more
combat it was yeah maybe
yeah i think or something like that yeah
and um reading in the magazines and
being a more combat fan and i just like
i
cannot wait for this but this game is
due out in like a year
in the uk so go to some holidays
pakistan it is there
so yes i went back um and i got to play
a game that wasn't officially released
to this poor day i don't know why
pakistan had the game before
well we had it yeah so that was that was
amazing and um there was there were a
myriad of games i can
let me back up that was a mortal kombat
game yeah more combat on playstation one
the first 3d game
i think was that the one with the
weapons i think so
i think over there annihilation or
something someone in chat can probably
google this there was one with weapons
that came out after the first 3d one i
think you talked about the one on
playstation 2. there was one on ps1
it had it introduced uh what's that um
and the boss with the witch shinnok i
think that was yes yes yes yes yes
yes mk 4 was the first one
it was the first 3d one yeah yeah yeah
shout out to pakistan
yeah man thanks for keeping it lit even
now this day
there are there they're gaming and game
pass i'm hearing from my cousins back
home they are
like yeah because you can't pirate games
now because of
online play you know if they could they
would but they don't
um
no but this is interesting perspective
like i said i'm so
it's so cool to hear your history
because again just hearing the
differences
hearing how to just gain access to games
initially they're noticing how things
have changed now like you're saying like
now there's like no power like
no one can get that and then they see
you talk about a service like game pass
actually flourishing you know what i'm
saying in the in the region like that's
pretty amazing i just see the
all these different shifts in the
industry that's pretty i'm going to know
after he gets past
uh playstation like i'm trying to get to
a certain zone
let's go to that zone that you after
playstation
yeah it's a good phone because that was
a pivotal
change so i just want the playstation 3
playstation 2
yeah playstation 2. and just bought it
and
i saw this ugly box called the xbox my
friend told me about it
i didn't know at the time because he
just told me hey this thing's got an
eight gig hard drive i'm wondering what
um and i wanted to hate the console
because i just paid money for this
playstation i barely could afford
and and i did but i didn't know
when i saw halo that was it oh my god
that's it done
in the middle east
and halo was i you know
there are very few games that i just
watched every video of that
every magazine just staring at the
screenshot of master chief
imagine all that hype ridiculous girl
against your level of hype and then
think
and having the game finally playing it
and actually exceeding your expectations
yes
very rarely i don't i can't think of an
against
but you nailed it i think that's that's
literally how it gets
okay so so we're in the zone where i
like
[Laughter]
so yeah xbox boom so he brought his
playstation he saw the xbox and was like
i want to hate on it
but damn is good and i need to follow up
on it so
did you you achieved the xbox did you
get an xbox
yeah so i got an xbox straight away i
had to borrow my friends xbox
right and then then i was just like dad
you need to buy me the xbox because this
is just
on another level my dad's like i just
bought you this other stuff
he said sell it sell it i don't care
so all right so we're into that part and
you're in the zone
with halo because i'm pretty sure that
you got halo with it because that was
your number one game at that time
um how did you play halo
one did you did you get halo 2 when it
came oh did i get halo 2.
come on okay so the reason why i'm
accent is because there's a space that
i'm trying to get to because i want to
know how did you interact
with your friends uh with the halo how
did the halo franchise
uh change with you and your friends
because you know you was able to um
put multiple controllers in and you know
and and play stuff so
i just want to know what was your
experience with that multiplayer aspect
of it
yes good question i i lan llan was just
oh nice here we go it's amazing i mean i
i mean i i
i love online gaming we'll never touch
that maybe the nostalgic feeling of all
of us
in that room with the tv so amazing
playing wizard uh
playing blood girl it's just
it's sick it was so sick yeah playing
together
xbox made it multiplayer gaming fun
again
like yes and then took it beyond borders
with the with the online play i was
always
see i was kind of bordering between pc
because i loved online
online gaming console then made it more
accessible where it wasn't for me even
on pcs are expensive
to this day so yeah so it was math
then it was a game changer halo 2 took
it to a whole
level oh yeah i remember i was not
looking back
there was no competition in that field
for you for a decade almost after yeah
and it was not looking back like
you were there and it's over over yeah
what's that i mean so i was primarily
xbox i still consider myself someone who
prefers the xbox platform more because
of the games
and the experiences that are available
on that platform i'm more multiplayer
centric so i like my multiplayer games
more
i'm more competitive online i'm all
about playing with my friends
having a community xbox is designed that
way yes from the content creators to the
wider community to the gamers
so it's just like a natural home
obviously with game of thrones like i've
got day one ps5
every at all consoles it's it's
it's xbox all the way for me because of
the experience that are there so
and i think a lot of the fanboy uh you
know dissension
they don't take don't think to count
their tastes so
people it's fed into people making fun
of single player games and xbox players
will say you're one and done games right
that's true you're right you're right
it's two different mentalities yes
i think that's one of the key reasons
that microsoft kind of went downhill
this generation because
i do feel like they lost what made their
platform their platform
and instead of trying to you know
develop another
you know rival six siege something that
would capture the audience something
that would really drive forward
they tried to chase whatever like the
minority on twitter wants and
and i feel like you know they suppose i
mean look look at how many
ips they made this generation they're
all single-player games they didn't
really
try multiplayer this generation besides
halo gears and forza
the only one i could really think of
that i felt like they had something was
titanfall and they let that slip through
their hands
so yeah i mean i will say this though it
might be slightly controversial but i
think i think it's much harder to make a
compelling
and uh multiplayer game than a single
player game
and that might be very controversial but
linear
story based single player game versus a
compelling multiplayer game in an
arena that is so saturated yep i just
it's really hard it's really i can't see
when 343 managed to do
the multiplayer right with halo 5 i i
breathe a silent relief like okay the
studio is competent because they did
something that's
really hard whereas with halo 4 i was
worried because they did a good single
player
yeah yeah where you go when you go on it
that does make a ton of sense um because
what's in and and from the board stand
room
standpoint you want to make something
that's going to give recurring
revenue or recurring engagement from the
same product
but it doesn't feel the same it feels
different every time you play it but it
also gives you a reward
that you have to come back to do this
again
and i think that's true when what you're
saying like you know it's harder to make
a multiplayer uh
game that is compelling to keep you
fixated on it
opposed to a single player game story
driven narrative because you actually
control the individual there
you really don't have any real control
in the multi uh
player space you know it's it's all
about the content
that's there and how the individuals
interact with said content
that that makes it you know um
compelling so you're you're right you're
right
no i feel like i feel there's it's
definitely some points to be made there
i mean and and
what i like what you said was it
referenced to why you
like the um the xbox ecosystem because a
lot of people
ask like yo i don't understand like why
you don't like you know not that we
don't like sony but
what gravitates us towards well we like
security oh my god
i mean seriously i like my credit card
to be there and i don't have to worry
about somebody driving down the block in
a ferrari i mean honestly i mean
seriously and you it's a
and a lot of guys is laughing old no
ferrari off of your joint
well this is not true sir cars have been
purchased with people uh
on their playstation accounts and you
can go check that out but it's
it's a terrible thing when you don't
feel safe in the environment that you
want to feel safe in
you know so i understand feeling safe
works for me this is why i love xbox
i feel safe thank you thank you for your
clarity you know people who just can't
follow you out of the blue they can't
message you they got a request
you know i really feel safe
yes i think we have established it just
envelops you in this one little
just had a curiosity and you felt safe
on xbox
i feel truly safe in the xbox ecosystem
i don't
really feel like i'm in danger oh you
know what i'm saying
like everybody should feel safe you know
that's all i'm just saying anyway real
quick we got to get a super chest
because we really left
off before i want to shout lord
you got this one you got this one right
yeah you got to get your zip up now you
got to get this zip up
come over here see you see
yeah now all you need to do is put the
beanie banging on it right there so
like oh my god yeah i was in the gym
with those guys
it was tough out here so soft get the
super chat before we walk first off
that's a big shout out to
lord fozzie aka kendra and hardy for
upgrading to lord gold no doubt
thank you sir wow then we have
lord michael askew with the 20 super
chat what up lords of the realm lord
skew and puppy of the realm
orion is in the building alex cog i got
you
yo the puppy is fire you got to see the
probably [ __ ] yeah
then we got pixel bit g two dollars with
the chat game preservation community
um chinatown yeah
[Laughter]
in chinatown the importer street fighter
2 arcade machines before they hit the
arcades in the state many battle
one without shout out to yeah penguin
village as well
penguin shout out to colbert and he said
we need nike air force ones with the iop
logo with the
i don't even care if we get somebody to
make uh you know remember the genuine
sneakers
[Music]
i don't care how goofy we look out here
then of course put those crests in the
chat for lord vogels cream
joining the round obviously in a minute
man
baby what's up vogue no doubt what else
we got
we're caught up we're good all right
cool cool luck man tremendous game in
history we could talk these games
for long but we never get the showdown
i love the perspective again you know
coming from where you come from then
going into
uk you know still doing your thing still
continuing your passion for gaming
awesome obviously the xbox err and all
that stuff but i gotta now ask about
your journey as a content creator you
know i'm saying just
getting into it so like what did you
start with and what specific aspects
kind of were you involved with content
creation first
so gamer daily when it first was created
was
um it wasn't a news aggregation platform
we were like a journalist
i started it up um and i was using a
site called n4g which my people might
know
yes and yeah so we're very quick
well i didn't want to badmouth the
platform it did give us uh
exposure we did we were the first people
in the world to leak the xbox one user
interface
wow yeah we did that got us in trouble
albert pinella and all that we have to
do
yeah yeah because it went it was um it
was a bit of a scandalous thing you know
everyone reported they invited us to the
press event and no one
said explicitly we couldn't record it so
i thought fine knowing
full well that the moment i go home and
i upload this
shit's gonna hit the fan and i did um so
but
i did that and it was it was a fun
project but
using n4g i realized one the community
was very toxic and one lopsided
lopsided in what pure sony if you bleed
even a
modicum of green hemoglobin you were
dead
it was it was just it was just not
balanced enough at the same time i met
uh my colleague asa the legend
he he's a genius man that guy has a
trillion good ideas
um and i said to him look we can do what
m4g do but better
with other things that we haven't even
launched yet because it's been heavy in
development man there's so much
so much going on and so many headaches
but
that's the whole i mean gamer daily's
morphed to something else now we want it
to be
what we're aiming for game on daily to
be is the database
everyone goes there the community are
there your streaming is out
there your gaming content is there your
communities and news that you like
it's hated to you so we've got systems
in place
so you form your circle soon we'll have
twitter integration so if your twitter
people come over
that's your circle of friends your
followers you've seen the content you
want to see
that's what we're aiming for but i found
recently
like i'll be honest with you man like uh
we
launched youtube like summer of 2020
and we're trying to reach out to all
different communities
playstation xbox nintendo yeah xbox
communities
is amazing i'm not just saying that
because i have a preference for it
because
look at the iron lords look at what
myriad of communities you've got maven
chat you've got
so many guys seasoned gaming so i mean i
can rip
you know rdx dealer or
those guys will call me help me out so
much those guys are legit
and we tried to find one community like
that on playstation we couldn't find it
so
and it's maybe it's out there but
there's a market difference between the
two communities but
i want to create or what game of daddy's
designed to do to create a positive
place
positive focus on positivity yeah people
want fire shots i'm like that i love
firing shots at times
you know me called you and my shirts
[Laughter]
you want to create a community for
people so if you like firing shots you
want to have chill you know with your
friends
you have a safe space there you have
your you know that's what we want to do
trying to do that and achieving it two
different things is very hard
it's an uphill struggle but yeah we're
getting there and i'm glad that people
like the problem
so no this is it's cool you know what
i'm saying like i said it's a very
unique thing
it's what i like about what you guys are
doing you know besides the news
aggregation aspect
you know you guys even hitting almost
like the tech
analysis you know i see nasa doing that
almost like from a digital foundry
standpoint
you got the tl dr did you also you know
rating online games your experiences i
see you have that apex up in there
you notice that you got all the battle
royale games going at it i'm glad you
watched it only like 200 people did
you better no bro i'm still mad at my
platinum games
interviewing i'm like damn i this was a
lot of work
for this but trust me people do
appreciate and um you look i hear what
you say to reference to the communities
don't give up on the other um platforms
as far as nintendo and sony because i
know what you mean
like people even though yes we do have a
preference for xbox you know a lot of us
here
but at the same time it's like because
the communities are so
outspoken so they're so giving right and
it's a little easier
right to get even from an executive
standpoint right it's a little easier
to get a hold of people industry people
and stuff like that but
i want to shout out they also you know
you got some positive playstation um
creators
you want to shout them out shout out to
kind of funny guys shout out to i missed
the bad bit and those guys you know what
i'm saying
he's amazing yeah oh yeah have you had a
bad bet on
yeah a couple of times actually yeah big
cloud there's a couple out there man so
definitely
you know still don't give up we still
we're still plugging for sony over here
too you know what i'm saying we got love
no we kings not what
time
was their fault though yeah but you know
what so
that can actually fit in the console
when you get on your high horse
and your situation starts to become
precarious because you're the king and
you're looking down on everyone as their
peasants and you don't have to
answer to them what are you talking
about games you get games when we give
it to you
here play this game that we had in the
bushes for a while
enjoy peasants enjoy right so
i i this i'm i don't care what any sony
dude says
oh you can't be rooting for the downfall
i am i want you to become
a divine and i want your games on my
platform
this the figures of lord king do not
reflect
the entire panel of the iron lords
podcast
it reflects the prophet
anyway like i was saying don't be afraid
to reach out
to the
and there are some executives that are
actually
positive and are definitely promoting
the brand the correct way
moving on can we can we do something
real quick
yes like i i'm tired of this perspective
that pete and this narrative people try
to roll that people who try to stay
in the positive light is just people who
won't like
for some reason people assume that that
if if you try to be a more positive
podcast that
all you do is never talk about the
negative like
that that's not true like when we talk
about a positive podcast
we talk about a podcast that still
criticizes but they do it respectfully
they don't sit there
and clown on the same subject for 30
minutes and then move on and then end up
back to the same subject that they just
climbed
on for 30 minutes like we will call cut
we will call companies out we've called
microsoft out
we've called playstation up we've called
nintendo out but the difference is
between a positive
uh podcast and not a positive podcast is
we do it respectfully we don't
we don't act like these people are just
data on a computer like they're human
people
and i get tired of people trying to use
a positive podcast in a negative way
oh they're they're just yes man over
there
you say that iop is a yes man you have
not watched
one episode talk to a young wolf in a
building
talk to
they don't agree with yo you gotta see
our background checks
he's absolutely right you know what i'm
saying you you can still be critical
you can still have to be a favorite of
something and to me just honestly it's
transparency you can love something
but you can also be critical and also
the kids when you disagree
be respectful the minute we see the
disrespect the personal attacks
yup out of here it's off with your head
you know how it goes like yeah like
small little jokes is one thing
but i i see communities literally just
like
like attack devs like look i didn't like
the whole cyberpunk thing i thought it
was real slimy
but i'm not gonna go above and beyond to
make like a
thousand videos
you know what i know i was using a diss
record i was like oh
damn like that's what i knew they
dudes made a diss record you know they
said they dropped the [ __ ]
so i was like yo i ain't all that type
of time anyway moving on
we got to keep it pushing man but on me
event salute to game on live man i love
what you guys doing unique
the news aggregation the fire like i
said i love ace we got to get him on
i love what he's doing you know what i'm
saying then you bring the sauce to
energy
so let's get into the sauce right quick
the last question i got to ask you man
like why does why do you gotta spice it
up a little bit and then i would also
shout out to uh
you and dodge man that video y'all put
out was howling
howling so talk about the sauce and talk
about that man
oh man so that it's just me man
being mental so the sauce comes to me
naturally
i've come from a region where there's a
lot of spice in our food naturally
talk yeah yeah
we've got some ridiculous things in the
works so when people look at asa they
look at me they're like
how the hell do you choose yeah you guys
are so it's so
funny i'm glad you said it because i'm
like you guys are so different
personality
like you're the spicy look he's very
very you know very cool very technical
very analytical
very chill quiet and you're the one on
the front street you're like
so like it's funny you said that
continue you could do i think it's an
amazing dad
it's a good balance it's good balance
because you know one side can go a bit
too far
than the other so if i'm going to widen
up too much then he will like pull me
back
you need to chill man these guys are
wrong on this you don't want to go
crazy on this narrative and it's just
natural tendencies we don't fake it man
like
in our normal conversation you see our
whatsapp groups the facts the
fire is so crazy if i harnessed
even 10 of that and put it on our videos
we probably get banned so
it's it's just a lot of um yeah it's a
great dynamic you can't make it up it
just happened
the forces worked to create that that
xbox video where we were destroying it
uh to that flat classic office space
scene that was uh
that was that was a lot for that as an
idea i had for a while
we've got loads of things to do like
that and the problem is 19 is
really three
you guys like the stuff you guys
understand because you guys have the
same energy if not
i'm speaking to brothers here because
you guys
embody that energy who wants to watch a
bunch of my dealer calls me and he says
no one wants to watch a bunch of boring
people to like snore about games so just
bring in the fire like you do in our
party chats i'm like that's
not a problem absolutely but yeah one
thing about is you're being you
you're having fun i think that you have
fun you know what i'm saying you'll
still be respectful you're still doing
this stuff but it's a unique mix man we
got a salute i love what you guys are
doing
it was a pleasure i was i was dope but
you had me on man i had i had a ball
you know that was a fun show that was a
great show and um yeah shout out to you
always bringing people in
and they like shout out to dodge long
live the sauce look at that
dodge i gotta get you on too man i gotta
get the lord crumpet himself and
the dark knight the dodge knight you
know what i'm saying with the animations
are you doing this thing man but yeah
salute to y'all
keep it pushing before i ask the final
question solvers get to catch up on the
um
super chat and then we got we got a
little bracket she loves
the chat so lords thank you brother oh
it's a little rap in the building
basement radar i can't regain what's up
captain flip-flop stop it again
he calls himself that you know i just
want to know how it is in that dead
foreign
and we got michael aka best. spiders
with the two dollars in chat cog
no let's be fair talk to let's be prayer
talk today
he now he gonna speak for the king
speaks for king
yeah please be clear
don't worry about that i'm proud to
stand alone because
when you win you win alone
[Music]
over the
[Laughter]
the favorite part of my sunday's iop
always entertaining thank you
references you already know you know
what i'm saying we all caught up
yeah we're good all right cool so look
man we got the sauce in the building we
gotta
ask him those questions we asked all the
lords in the realm that guest
i need those top five video games or
franchises
of all time from lloyd gas oh fine
geez okay um you're personal um
i guess from number one for me it will
be halo like uh
okay okay um although we'll see how
infinite turns out
that could affect it with the lift it
can affect it massively
um quake will be a very close second
first quake reference
yeah quake 3 arena was i went i had a
56k
modem and even then i was learning stuff
to to the degree that i actually met the
quickly world champion
joined the first ever went head to head
with him
and he was like i don't know how you're
so good even though you exclusively play
um on a 56k modem and that was because i
used to wake up at five o'clock in the
morning practice on nightmare difficulty
yeah so that was uh that was again that
left an impression
for me i think
the other other five franchises are a
bit
harder to say um because they're all
over
the legend of zelda ocarina oh
oh okay you went straight to it so i can
really tell okay okay that's great that
was nothing touches
again there's one of those like you saw
the game it looks sick and then
when you actually played it it was a
whole different ball game do you co-sign
this
yes
yeah he said it quick yes oh skyward
sword no
[Laughter]
he said dude
oh
[Laughter]
it's not a franchise but it's just
amazing
yeah go to fire down
was revolutionary absolutely one last
one
the last one i i think instead of a
franchise i'll have to give it to a
studio that i still think
despite what it's achieved is um not
rated enough and that's respawn
entertainment and that falls teeth
titanfall
call of duty modern warfare 2 um that
was infinity war that became
because they had to get that 60 frame
patch now i'm playing
i haven't made a whack game yet no
it's definitely true i i would honestly
say that you know they're the top five
of the best devs this generation
yeah living flame says now i'm in love
they might
they might not necessarily have made the
better games
but they haven't made a miss and i think
that means more than anything
exactly slow that's a tremendous five
and last one man um this is a i'm very
curious to see where you go with this
one
you can only pick one favorite console
of all time
how are you gonna do be like this
pakistan let's go oh i have to be the
sega
genesis
yeah the thing that started it oh i
can't that i'm sure there's not many
sony fanboy i say your fanboys out there
they're probably xbox fanboys now
because of what happened
is still holding the sega flag high
that's right we we're out here for blood
i mean i mean so do i just don't blame
the sonya 1 is a close one and so is the
original xbox
um so you know playstation one was
magical but sega
mega drive or genesis beautiful yeah
what an era what an
era man tremendous history man rocking
and rolling i love these stories it's
good to hear different perspectives at
home
yeah man guys is all fine the chat
loving you
i love you for sure man you know what
i'm saying so uh if you obviously could
still hang out if you want definitely
please rock out with us if you want if
you
have to go just let us know um salvation
super chat
yeah we got a midway monster with the
five dollar super chat glad to catch the
podcast guys bringing that sauce
have a great show high busters looks
amazing right
yo shout out to my man midway we've been
rocking he's getting uh i'm hot we
just rocking with kaiba getting the high
ball busters on you know what i'm saying
during the game play
so he's rocking and rolling make sure
you stop picking my character you know
the inside joker
but anyway so we all cut up
yeah we're good all right cool man let's
get this poll results on guys you're
good right you still rocking
oh yeah of course i don't doubt my man
so all right last week pro results are
i say that's a problem you know oh my
god i give the same option you know i
understand we're running long
you have to take off for something but
yours is mad you're pushing people
you're too bad rude with yours
you'll be like oh so you're getting
ready to leave right or
[Music]
my intro okay was such a prominent part
of it i was here to talk games so
thank you so much exactly out of respect
i just had to ask because we tend to go
long
i'm gonna start actually being rude you
could see the difference oh my gosh
you were to do lord roughness anyway
last week
please don't ever say that again
last week's results the people had
spoken to the question
when microsoft's quick reversal on their
recent xbox live
gold price increase and stands for
free-to-play games do you think it's
wrong
to now shower praise on microsoft for
correcting this mistake
the winner of the four-way ilp is not
the four-way three-way
ilp poll at 51 percent of the vote was
gamers one companies rarely reverse
course that quickly coming in at second
it's not even quickly
they rightly do it at all at all coming
in at second place at 32
percent of the vote was i don't care but
when y'all going to rally against these
70
games though a last place at 16
of the vote was stop praising them
microsoft should have never made the
mistake to begin with
lord guys what are your thoughts on this
poll sir
yeah so it's it's i kind of agree with
all of that
because respect to them for doing the
u-turn
shame on them for even thinking that was
a good idea
and then it's gonna like we talked about
this yesterday on go live
it's and someone in chat made a good
point that well oh no actually that was
asa he's always good points
um he was saying well from now on all
that good will that seemed to be piling
on
yeah it seemed like all that good work
was undone you had that
new subreddit uh it's a really good
twitter
thing as well and they've been spreading
a lot of
positive xbox news and then they when
that broke off shared a meme of a cat
or teary diet you know that little me
yes yes yes
and they're like seven months of
spreading good news and this happens
so like everyone was just like
they had to try
to try to see if you're still awoke oh
my god
we're trying to get that we're trying to
push past that 20 million
[Music]
trying to get to that 20 million mean no
they're at 20 million we're trying to
get past that sir
savage savage so anyway man so we are
caught up let's get right into the topic
explore king do you want me to frame
this
yes please frame it for the god yes
let's go
huge week huge week uh um you know xbox
game pass numbers a lot of first of all
let's talk about the uh the quarterly
revenue uh report
for microsoft so in their qt to earnings
51 year-over-year increase in gaming
revenue why is king diddy bombing
including
four including why is he diddy bopping
but i'm saying numbers
including 40 gains across xbox content
and services
xbox game pass has now hit solve 18
million
wow it says plus so 8
18 5 let's give it 18. 18. whatever you
want
18 plus million subscribers i mean in
that case if you're just going to go
through that crazy kind of
methodology that kind of logic
you know i'm saying again imagine that
50 million
who rounds to the nearest millionth and
a half
we found out it was 15. 115. thank god
let's let's let's keep we going to keep
it how we go
my bills don't have the same mentality
you know what
this is true because when xbox was
selling um consoles year after year
and it was going up they kept us at the
25. oh they only sold 30 million but
playstation numbers just kept going up
right
so we gonna keep y'all at two million
playstation now
uh uh people whatever you call you guys
and game pass dude the next 20. the next
time um
playstation let's say next month they
come out and they
stop dancing
they say that let's say the next time
that playstation comes out and says
okay you know playstation plus and
playstation now they're 20 plus million
like that's a lie
see they go there you know why it's a
lie because it's fabricated it's not
true
moving on with the numbers we got data
on
the legendary
gaming what's going on boss can you hear
us sir
maz get your levels get us get his all
the way all together
you don't want to have his head set on
he doesn't have his head set on he's
figuring it out
he's he's doing this so he's he's going
to get it together he's going to get it
together but he's just hacked into the
system
we'll get to bazi in a minute but uh
yeah man so again tremendous revenue
growth again xbox
game pass and then of course xbox live
gaming network now
has over 100 million monthly active
users so tremendous report
this is lord king's topic lord king what
did you want to bring to the realm
in reference to the revenue we pretty
much know what he wants to bring to the
room and that little
that dance the arguments he's been
starting
can you hear me yes there we go
legendary
love mods gaming what's up just watch
your video this morning poland's
fighting this is yeah
you know what i'm saying so what's up
king what what do you feel about this
news that you wanted to
share so eagerly to the realm why why do
you sound so sarcastic
first first first i gotta put on the
sith lord hoodie
okay okay okay
y'all was talking numbers before
oh my god this is how this is how
when you don't remember when you first
saw darth maul in the
you don't remember when you background
saw him in the background like
so uh i was talking numbers before
microsoft doesn't talk numbers because
they understand when the numbers
what did you just say did he just say 18
plus
million you've been you've been building
up to this plane
million million
so so this is the payback from people
who've been coming at the
xbox community for for doctors
retribution was at hand
so mad dude was talking about oh but
that's x that's
microsoft forever let's get to the
gaming aspect of it brother
let's get to the 50 more
check this out if you had your check
right you get your check
and your boss said i'm gonna give you 50
more of what you had
boy oh hell yeah i'll take that
so i thought microsoft was in dire
straits yeah
the twitter twitter said the xbox gaming
division wasn't making money a couple
years ago
yeah obviously that that's a couple
years ago how about this morning
you know and listen your body's not
smiling from ear to ear with your foot
this does not reflect on anybody on this
panel
right i don't care how you sony guys
feel
you jump on my timeline when i don't at
you
and i'm just talking positive xbox stuff
so this is the point
in the game where i'm coming for your
throats
i'm going to tell you right now what's
inevitable
right you always said well microsoft
xbox
needs to use microsoft's backing their
money you know to go out and purchase
things because
they have all this money and they're
just lit okay now the beast is awoke
ominous maximus really
said you know what phil you on to
something
show me show me how we can make more
money and then they did
so so so dominance he he showed him the
millions now that's that's where we at
now we have the millions millions
he's produced fruit from this he's at a
point right now
he's at super saiyan blue he said he
said
he's that super saiyan blue right now
some more some more
dragon ball okay continue continue
at least it's not called needle because
i know he does nothing about him
you guys are trying to figure out uh
what what is his next move his next move
is more active positions and more power
because you get to the point where
you're just power hungry right so you
you guys i've told you before when you
walk the beast you poke the beast now
they see blood in the water so out of
curiosity king what what when does uh
when is microsoft's ultra instinct when
does that happen
oh well we already know ultra instinct
is about to be achieved
you see them powering up right now i saw
twitter right now
going crazy talking about who's the next
acquisition it's going to be on the
level of bethesda
what we're already not getting those
games who else games is going to be
closed off from us
get out of lay down oh god the knees
it's time to be back
these are just that we got a better d
when when are we going to give it up to
them
when are we going to say yo you know
what not for nothing
they are entity within their self it's
not microsoft
they're generating this their self
actually so
you you guys are saying well they don't
have any first party titles but
i care about well somebody's caring
about these titles
millions do agree now just to play both
sides
here um i'm going to i'm going to take
king spot real quick
uh cognito as well now what would you
say to people say well you know i would
say a lot of
you know the growth has to do with the
pandemic and people are stuck in houses
and
you know is it is it fair to say that
stuff might to go back to normal
once the pandemic starts to come to an
end or or do you think this is just the
new num
net numbers from now on so all right
to your point is valid because the whole
industry as a whole
saw growth yes within this period of
time this is not just an isolated
incident that has happened to microsoft
themselves
this has happened to each and every last
one
of the major three and you know stadia
is not included um
they're the only ones that died during
the pandemic
[Laughter]
they're the only ones that could not
show growth
they're the only ones that got it it
just was like oh we can't make it
how do you do that first of all we got a
shout out to phil illuminist
i told you this red sneakers was the
problem i remember the first conference
i remember your very own
show them the door but nintendo has
shown growth and they continue to show
growth
with the same hardware which is hard to
do now these new consoles are showing
growth with new hardware
in a pandemic where financially we're in
a crunch
i don't care what anybody said
everybody's financially crunched right
now
yeah right everyone because when one
hurts everybody hurts
right so to show growth in this position
is crazy
digital growth is at an all-time high
this is actually precipitated the
the demise of physical i believe in my
opinion
because you don't have to social thing
yeah right you understand this is that's
the real social discipline you don't
have to go to the store
at all right you know you're right so
yeah
i i do feel what you're saying at it and
and as far as going back to the norm
once you're in the club you're in the
club yeah
i think it's one of those things where
just like any other subscription service
like
you sort of get it and forget it like my
netflix is go
after going up to damn near 20 bucks and
i just i noticed it because i logged in
from something
from from this laptop that i haven't
used in forever
so when i logged in it was like yeah
just so you know and i'm like oh really
i didn't know
it was going up and it's just like okay
at that point i guess i could cancel it
if i wanted to but
i'm not going to i feel like
that isn't the the scene for the most
people
i feel like you know a lot of the people
that get stuff they get stuff for value
you know they get stuff for what they're
going to use and i feel like a lot of
you
you don't get that because it's just
normal you're used to it but i think a
lot of people
you know they see it go up they see it
go to twenty dollars and like
the first thing they think of is like do
i really need netflix what do i watch on
netflix
you know sometimes on the game pass
thing you know
that's why i'm saying like it's very
important that they actually really
start
trying uh you know showing a good road
map you know they've showed
a relatively good road map but they they
need this
exactly any road map when it comes to
game pass i think every month is like a
bag of treats
i honestly believe every month and
within three times within the month
they have drops and then you find out
because you go on
uh let's say you go on mods you you
watch mods and mars tell you this will
be launched in game pass
right you know and then he gets to the
technical parts about the back door
stuff that you know we don't really know
about but
he knows about to teach us but i feel
as a whole the industry is showing
growth like you said yeah
i'll give you a good example real quick
when
uh when stadiu is giving pretty much
people for six months for free
what's the first thing you did after you
got that i know i ain't using this
afterwards
disable auto so when it comes to
scenarios like that you can have
anything
compelling but that's my point that's my
point right
you know and they have a little bit on
there too my point is
is that just because the price of people
forget i don't believe that people
forget stuff they might forget a month
or two
but if there is not enough value to keep
people going first that's that first
charge that they forgot about the second
charge they forgot about
they are unsubscribing i'm gonna give
you i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you your point because
you said a road map i think that bag of
tree thing helps
them keep the subscribers right because
you are
always guessing like what's next i don't
know what to buy
because uh if i purchase this game and
then two weeks later it comes out inside
game pass
you're kicking yourself down the street
right so you and this has happened to me
this has formed my whole
purchasing philosophy right if i don't
feel that a game
uh is ever going to make it to game pass
then i buy that game
right now i'm saying that you okay so
you said that they
unsubscribe once they get to the deal
part mm-hmm
the fact that they got i'm just saying i
know what you're saying it's it's
like they give you the first six months
free right let's let's use stadia as an
example
this is how they would have got me
whenever they would have launched diablo
right but they didn't they said it's
coming they said it's coming and it
still hasn't gotten here and when it
gets here that's when i'm going to start
my stadium subscription if it's not
completely gone by that time
right but and then like you said i'm
going to disable
auto reoccurrence because they haven't
shown the value in it right but
to be at 18 million plus yeah right
that's gross
that's showing you that people see the
value
and they continue with the services
because it grew from when it was what
was that we was at 15 million and i was
telling
you guys it was more than that before
right and then i'm telling you guys it's
more than that now
right and the growth is going to show
when this is the problem
these dudes wanted us to talk numbers
right and i'm say us because i'm game on
xbox i don't care no
do i financially make any money from
xbox yeah from whatever stocks that i
got from them
that which is not a lot i didn't get
rich when um
gamestop did what they did to others
right yeah
i'm still in my basement with my statue
so when you see the background change
then you know i got rich
continue right but you see dc statues
back there no
that the bag is there but but you you
have to understand the revenue
end on end and showing growth in a
situation where
people thought it was a dead end that
means it's a
viable living environment that is
flourishing
and i understand the pandemic may play
uh a part in some of this stuff but it's
that pandemic
is not isolated just to microsoft of
revenue
that pandemic is a global pandemic so
anyone showing any type of growth
during this hardship is a positive right
and that's that's one of the things that
i'm saying it's like look right now they
see value because they're stuck in the
house
some people don't have a job but before
the pandemic the growth was going up
that's the thing but it's skyrocketed
during the pandemic well
it catalyzed it i don't i think it's
gone to the point of no
the the casuals who would unsubscribe
are the kind of people who would carry
on letting their subscriptions run
anyway
xbox is the game gameplays don't
i have to disagree with you like i i've
worked a dish network i've talked to
multiple people about netflix and i've
talked to multiple people about all the
absence on dish network
people do not just let their stuff go
wild like that they don't
they might do it a month they might do
it two months but sooner or later if
that
service isn't having value they are
unsubscribing right and it's
about the key differential between the
two services what we've seen game pass
do is not even
it hasn't even started munching on a
sensu bean this is just uh
basic stuff when he goes when he starts
going powering up then it's super saiyan
blue it's too early king david
pronounced it way too early
xbox is capable of doing it's to happen
soon and then i just can't see it slow
down
when there's studios that they've
acquired and they wait
you don't think that super saiyan blue
you're not not there yet you're actually
you don't think they had super saiyan
blue right now
that's red nah they're not even blue
okay so you don't think
okay check it out no no no no no i gotta
go into this oh god
we gotta get bonds but i'm saying
and i'm gonna give you how they achieved
super saiyan blue
all right right they was powering up
with the xbox series and xbox x and
series s
right yeah successful launch
with game pass and showing growth
right successful launch
with the series x and s
while maintaining games
inside the service right because the
service was still weak and growing
right yeah purchasing bethesda
mm-hmm we're at blue
[Music]
i feel like if we're if we're going off
like you know dragon ball
club i feel like i feel like
buying but uh buying the first set of
studios was super sad by
buying bethesda super saiyan 2 and then
all we ain't talking about super saiyan
3 because the show don't really talk
about super saiyan 3
and then and then if they buy sega
that's super saiyan blue
that's super saiyan god the trajectory
is going up but i'm not
yeah it's not dead yeah because at the
end of the day i'm going to get to my
point we'll talk about
the disparity from the 18 but i gotta
get finished with god's thought and i
got to get mods in and guess he's been
waiting patiently just smiling
[Laughter]
so god you wanted to finish your thought
that i want to get margin
i don't think players xbox has even
beaten freezer yet but there you go
it's a sony freezer right here that's
savage
no doubt don't tell my majin buu to me
man you've been patient brother good to
have you good it's been a while to have
you back in a row so good to see you
number one
and uh yeah man how are you feeling
about the numbers are coming out
you know 18 million game pass
subscribers you're seeing the revenue up
51
you know a lot a lot of positive xbox
division numbers right
so what do you what do you feel about
this yeah well
first of all thanks for the invite you
know always nice to be here
um yeah i mean i think
this is just the beginning um people i
mean
we kind of are all excited about the
positive numbers and that kind of stuff
and i think kind of xbox and microsoft
generally speaking needs that
it just shows that the you know
investment they've made in
you know gaming overall is kind of
starting to pay off
um in terms of so i'm not really going
to get into the
you know the financials and that kind of
stuff because i'm not really good with
that
you know we've got king here we've got
could you put it please in dragon ball z
yeah i mean for me to follow
so um but
but in terms of in terms of game pass
and the numbers and stuff i think that
they are just getting started because
like if you think about the fact that
you know they haven't really released
anything big incorrect
like i mean really since gears 5
i mean that's that's the reality of it i
mean you know you could you could argue
that maybe flight simulator on pc and
uh you know gears was you know i would
count the pc part i would count theirs
for sure because that's still in the
same service yeah
so so so you know maybe maybe that but
like
but still like i've heard and i'm not
sure if that's um
legit legitimate information but i've
heard that you know
like there's there's way more people on
um with game pass on xbox
than pc right now right so so i i guess
you know once those games start hitting
uh um
you know xbox in in the in the future um
and i guess
medium is kind of like this you know
small kind of gym i guess
um you know this is just the beginning
then we will start seeing those numbers
because like you know right now like
king said that oh they've got bethesda
and
and you know obviously all these studios
and stuff but realistically speaking
they hadn't really
released anything i mean they've shown
trailers and that kind of stuff that's
all cool because we know what's coming
and we kind of prepare but
you know i'm not like if i were to be on
the fence i mean i'm not i've got game
pass i use it every day
really right so but like if i were to be
a consumer
that is not on xbox or don't have game
pass yet
and i was to see all those you know
trailers and that kind of stuff would i
subscribe straight away
no you know because i mean why would i i
mean if i won those games other games
that that they are still working on i
will just wait and subscribe when these
games start here coming right and you
know
really you know i think that that hello
infinite
that's when it's going to restart uh you
know happening when we will see
like way bigger numbers because people
will just
basically you know uh start is seeing
those bigger numbers and then
you know we still know not because like
microsoft talks about these secret
projects and that kind of stuff that
they
still want to release apparently this
year right but even this year if you
think about games like stalker 2
flight simulator on xbox well of course
halo infinite
there's rumors about forza horizon
5. yes listen you know every single time
i see
microsoft exec executive whether that's
you know um you know phil spencer or
even financial
microsoft guys they keep talking about
you know starfield right
so that game is closer to release than
people
think right you know in my opinion so
when those games start hitting
you know i think they will really reach
those numbers very quick
um so you know um
king said that oh they are there at this
super saiyan letter already right
at the end of the day you know yet at
the end of the day it's all about
you know the content once the content is
going to be there
the numbers will come odds mobs they
just took a senzu bean what are you
talking about
that with the references no i i hear
what basically said and at the end of
the day
to king's point though the king's
defense um you know it is still
impressive to see the incession
even though like you're saying mine's
like those games have not hit yet those
we have not seen the fruits all the way
up to
without the with the game son yeah like
i see them
it's kind of impressive crazy it's
ball now
he's exposed oh my god
anyways so before you go get the super
chance over to europe
uh hold on a second we have uh
we have lord roughness five pound super
chat
um xbox has have made back that 7.5
billion but that's the purchase
twice so even though phil won't say the
numbers say everybody that's the title
will be exclusive
yeah but we're going to make sure that
the service games is over there
we we do want your money all right don't
don't get this wrong
elder scrolls online listen everything
that's for a service we want to charge
you
we can have it
xbox 360 was super saiyan xbox one was
yamcha
yeah we got bet style spiders two dollar
super chat now
more like xboxes jiren and p.s is
krillin
all of these dragon ball references i'd
be like i know nothing i don't know
speaking out of the way you bring in the
other demographic
the living flame with the five dollars
if phil doesn't have halo on burger
on burger king wrappers and drinks
during the promo period he isn't doing
the advertising justice
oh yeah it's going down that's going
down okay they got it you gotta go it
was ready with taco i think yeah was
ready to talk about yeah
like mcdonald's and burger king is that
small sony
but uh taco bell and in and out burgers
and all that you know uh
ground root stuff microsoft tends to
keep the air closer to them
i mean i don't i don't know what's that
about but
really i noticed that their marketing
tends to skew like taco bell is number
one for those guys for some weird reason
one word on the you know marketing side
of things of xbox um
you know like poland is this country
where they spend a little bit more of
money but not too much but
the playstation is really better but you
know ever since
medium actually launched like i see uh
medium and xbox gameplay
in in advertisements at least here in
poland
i see that i do want to bring that up
that you know a lot of people
always have that concept or like you
know i just so under and you know
a lot of it is unknown knowledge because
we don't know exactly what's going on
behind microsoft stores
but a lot of people are confused exactly
like how is microsoft making money
when they're spending all this money and
they're you know only ten dollars a
month you know the game
60 it's like right it's aimed for
multiple different scenarios one
not everyone that has subscribed to game
pass was going to buy the game anyway
when you have an entity such as game
pass that the games are going in
you no longer have to spend crazy
amounts of money on marketing through
all of the games all you have to do is
spend market marketing game pass
and you have to market and then you
market the game with game pass
like so you're probably spending a
fraction of the marketing that you're
spending on the games individually when
you're when you're
marketing them all together with gameboy
remember
the talk was you know everyone that's in
the subscript subscriber is
a one dollar subscriber you know they're
bleeding money
putting into this it's it's it's just
this all this doom and gloom and they
gotta hope
to you know recoup the money and you
know all this stuff those are the same
people
that uh that always be telling all you
know i don't
i don't ever see xbox on on commercials
on tv
there's a reason for that tv is on the
downward spiral like
crazy unless you're when i was at dish
network i was always in meetings for
this like unless you're
promoting on monday not football
or you know sunday morning football i
think
or amc's the walking dead you're not
getting your money's worth anymore
you're just not it's
easier to what they call direct
uh advertising exact audience that
they're
they're trying to aim for you know you
get the
the big streamers you get the the
youtubers that's who you want to market
your stuff
and then you still mark it with the
super bowl because we see
xbox stuff with the super bowl you see
adam knows
marketing you know shout out mr aaron
greenberg
i know i asked you to be your assistant
but i think uh attic is more qualified
but i'm gonna say this uh guys i love
the sauce i love the background 100 you
know what it is
but um um the medium already made back
their budget we're going to get to that
maybe
i'll get to that we're going to get to
that that's what we got mods in here
but continue solving we get all the
super chances we caught up yeah i think
we did all right cool
you're brought up i mean yeah i mean
listen
the growth was gonna happen regardless
to what um
i i disagree with attic in that i i know
that p
he's seen it firsthand that people do
pay attention there are people who
really pay attention to these
these services they're paying for and if
they're not getting the value out of
them they cut them out
but i honestly don't think that is the
majority of people especially depending
on
the level the level of subscription that
you get right let's say when i worked a
dish
i i would take anywhere from a thousand
to three thousand phone calls a day
uh i would i would say jesus two
to three hundred of those were always
about subscription services they want to
cancel because
when they subscribe to something like
netflix on the boxes on dish or you know
who or whatever
their support now because they work
there in about a year and a half like
they they think that you have to call us
to cancel that so think about it
two to three hundred out of three to
four thousand
that means the rest of them that
assuming right we're just assuming the
rest of you
now assume that a lot first off you know
not everyone know every not everyone is
is ignorant to the fact that you have to
call us so they're not calling in
general
a lot of dish networks audience is the
older audience
so they're not calling because they
don't have the services
all right so then removing removing from
that the whole
the tv aspect of it i think the gaming
audience is a little bit different
that's what you're about to say there's
two different audiences yeah they're
very they're two different artists and i
think the gaming audience
once you invest in a service like this a
game pass let's say you're a casual
player
i think just the fact that you know
you're getting new games regardless of
what they are on a monthly basis
i think that keeps the new player in
because it's like wait a minute i
i i'm not somebody buys a lot of games
now now we're not talking about people
for getting to unsubscribe now you're
talking about value that's keeping
people under service which is your right
the argument we're talking about how how
is growth going to continue once the
world what unquote
goes back to normal no no my argument
was always that people don't just forget
to unsubscribe to stuff that was my
argument
i know that you know because regardless
all the pandemic did
is give people hands on to try the
service that's all they did they had
nothing
because the people tried the services
like i sat here for a month didn't play
one damn game on here i'm unsubbing like
that but when people try more you know
it's like our podcast we have a great
product when people
get more access to our podcast they tend
to stick around so you know you've got
to provide content right if you're not
providing compelling content that no
one's going to
yeah who's giving you the hot chip
challenge
took that song
he's in the chat trying to pick on me
now where's addicts yeah
yeah man so i for me i i think the
growth is there
i think it's just going to continue to
happen and like mod said the bangers are
coming
and that's going to entice even more
people because the funny thing is right
you would
you don't expect necessarily hardcore
gamers to all jump on it either because
hardcore gamers are very sort of picky
and selective sometimes
so once the hardcore see that those
games are there
and the quality games right because we
still have to see how good those games
are
and they're good and you were talking
about the star fields of the worlds the
halo infinites of the worlds the
obviously the forza gears um and
whatever else comes down the pipeline
that becomes a very compelling argument
for those numbers to continue to grow
i beg the difference off i already think
we already got the hardcore hardcore was
ready and they said then they suffered
but this yeah but you know okay this
hardcore like
it's hardcore like us to jump in for day
one right right but then there's
hardcore
yeah no but no this hardcore is like
they take really hard lines on things
like
i'm not touching this because i feel
this is that this this way the other way
whatever
i got those dudes on my timeline i i
know exactly but see those are the dudes
that
you know i think those are the cappers
be honest with the cappers i think those
captain actually have game pass i think
it actually could be
i think listen in my heart i believe
christopher hart has an xbox
[Laughter]
right now is is on the series as he's
playing the medium and he
and he's in the corner quiet and he has
a different name and a different game
attack he probably got
jw he's probably j.w he switches over he
switches up like like jacob
oh no
his game pass was directed towards the
people
it's it's directed towards people like
us that like the first party stuff but
it's mainly directed towards
you know mothers fathers people that
family you know
they they get they get something to go
to store get an xbox they're like okay
what do i buy
and then the person's like all you have
to do is get really subscribe to game
pass
because he gives you access to this more
than 100 games that's all
i tell you i have two co-workers who
came to me and they asked me about you
know
about xbox that their their kids love
xbox but they were not aware at
all about game pass and they asked me oh
they he wanted this game that game the
other game right
i'm like two of those games on game pass
right what's game pass and i'm like what
yeah many people do not know and it's
just like it
once once that that light is turned on
it's like why would i not do this
and turn it off yeah it is
and that's the thing i i just think it
just i just think it continues to
perpetuate i think
if these games coming out this year
continue to hit
and and i think part of the end game too
ryan for for microsoft is
once you start hitting that 40 million
subscriber
50 million subscribers now the argument
could be made to the third parties
for big games saying listen you're
losing money by not putting it day one
in game pass
you're losing money by not putting this
game day one and game pass on the xbox
platform because guaranteed
you're making x amount of money day one
because of the amount of game pass
subscribers you have
and phil spencer said that people are
coming to them before he's maximum it's
really a spencer
ominous maximus aurelius spencer
[Music]
whatever they're saying whatever once
they hit that once you give me a big
[ __ ]
is the last one that's all you need to
know exactly and that's when it's gonna
fold again see this
y'all don't know how close you're all to
folding really don't understand
how much he's he's he's he's at the yo
sob this is this is for the dominoes
players he's
at the end he's getting really young
the dominoes on the table i'm telling
this is the part uh right
before the punch you know the punch
you you you boxing and this is the part
right before they wake you up
look at the guys over here you're like
what the hell
happened and you got to watch the replay
you're not focused on what's real it's
the sleight of hand that's happening
there's a red that
we are literally
this close to the finish and i told you
jesus
i said i said just started it
that's the wild part look at the bell
ringing all right
so so get this get this all right
game pass was built for the pandemic
right no i'm talking about
it it inherently takes advantage
of the pitfalls right of a pandemic
right not saying that they built it for
the pending i'm telling you
yeah oh absolutely it takes advantage
it fits perfectly this is the necessity
of the pandemic right
okay so now that it takes advantage of
the disadvantages of said pandemic
right and these consoles is releasing
how they're releasing and they're
getting in the wild but the same time
i know for a fact that there's not 18
million
xbox series s or uh series x sold
right right so that means the install
base is growing
from the previous base that was already
installed
right right and also growing with the
new base
this is the scary part
now as that grows and they're going
forward the games are not released yet
to drive like addicts said the the the
base
forward right now as sovereign said the
hardcore that put that line there
right those dudes are still holding out
hope
that bethesda games is going to be on
another platform
they need to be show and prove we come
from the strong proof part
you know we got to know right if it's
going to be there or not facts
yeah and i think end of the day to hit
when we start hitting those numbers it
is gonna i'm gonna be honest i think
it's gonna be on the pc side
it's the pc that's gonna drive it when
you see those numbers because i think at
the end of the day
we're still not gonna get the amount of
consoles sold that they would like to
see sold this year right not gonna
happen um
i think the growth is gonna be on the pc
side i think
those games a star field a halo day and
date
on on on pc which you've never seen
it's like that stuff starts to happen in
addition to maybe getting some big third
party at some point
we're looking at a lot more subscribers
right dude
i i'm gonna be honest i think the ace in
the hole is the pc side of gameplay
guys you got a point i know you want to
jump in i saw you before mm-hmm
guys sauce
i'm just oh yeah i heard you had jumped
in before but also all right so
one last word if i can yeah
because you actually bring an
interesting topic like you know the fact
that
um you know pc may bring their and the
numbers but
um also remember that there's like
you know steam users i mean some people
say that's like 200
million um you know active gamers there
right
so that's 200 million that's a lot of
people but remember
that um game pass i mean i don't know
how to call it right now xcloud is it
the rx cloud
yes um that service is going to be
available
on pc this year now imagine
all these another like couple of
hundreds
of um million of uh people with
you know low specs um laptops
i mean let's face it like you know most
people have got
like some sort of like you know internet
you know
you know a laptop that they just use for
internet or whatever right
now the internet speeds may not be there
yet with a lot of
these people but still that's still a
huge install base
so these people all they will need is
just a laptop
um xbox controller and decent
internet right yeah um so with all you
know 5g
everyone has got you know like you know
the access to 4g right now and that kind
of stuff
you know i'm not saying that every game
will be good for game
for for xcode and that kind of stuff but
there's so many people
you know um on laptops that i may
actually get into that service this way
right yeah
it's mobile that's where the yeah that's
where the cake is at that's where
microsoft is aiming
squarely at why amazon are going so
hammered at google
it's mobile it's com the fact that
have you tried xcloud on my phone i've
got a razer phone with the razer oh
you this is the samsung
s12 but the razer what's it called
jungle cat right
the controller and so it turns into a
switch kind of yes like this
with x-cloud fire i play crack down on
my way to work
on the train that the mo the feeling of
that it wasn't perfect because the
service has a lot of work to do
yeah once i that's that's on a 4g
network in
but when 5g comes in it's over that's
when you
king david stop blowing your load too
early
the reason why i'm not blowing the load
early i didn't say
that he initiated super saiyan blue i'm
saying he's at super saiyan blue
because all right and the reason why i
could say this
is because i saw the benefit of this see
i already set that trap for you
way before when this win when when when
the podcast started
i said traps the whole time all right so
if you're watching for this said trap
i want you to remember this trap that i
set for you right and then you fell
right into it it was beautiful
i got to let everybody that didn't know
in the beginning i was playing a raid
this week
attic had to leave he was playing on his
console
yeah he got to his job and took out his
phone and proceeded to finish
said raid there you go and this is
the part of where you were talking about
with that group that phone group
right let's say let's say okay and he
was he was seamless attic was fantastic
you can tell me that he wasn't playing
on the console
if he didn't tell me that he was on
mobile
i would not know the difference right oh
wait are you talking about the night
that i jumped on
yes i was definitely on my console fan
well he called you bro
i brought the calls to the world he
brought it to work
he couldn't take it to work with him
excuse me for your flexibility
i had i had a hunch that you guys
wouldn't finish and i couldn't let my
people go like listen
thank you the fact that you can actually
bring that to work
we're not even going to get into his
work situation how crazy all right
we're exposing too much but look super
chatter that i gotta get my balls off
uh let me see we have black ronin with
the five dollars we chat xbox about to
be
the the ju the juvenile juve
grass glasses and 25th bam in this game
c tower of god i eat that whole bull i
don't know that
that was i guess that was something that
must have been the addict translation
daddy did he say anything
that we do need to know about people who
got their references out there
but it was i don't know what he said you
know you're looking at the chat right
now
then we have a shane tomlin with the
five pound super chat let's talk game
past 20 million users
at 10.99 uk a month or let's say
to be kind three sony games at 70 times
10 times 10 million
do the math who gives you that but
who did that for you and we have a genre
with the 2
super chat i was supposed to cancel
netflix 10 years ago yeah i think
yeah a lot of people will say that same
thing
i'm in that boat too fast that's it
that's it all right look i'll make this
because we don't sit below in this we
gotta move all right yeah man look
tremendous growth you know all
i i hear with king's coming i know i
know he's got his chest out he's feeling
good you know what i'm saying and
and rightfully so you know at the end of
the day it was told
to us you know by numerous pundits in
the twitter verse
that you know that the xbox you know
game division
wasn't doing good like the thought was
microsoft is doing well
but the xbox game division is bleeding
money
right and they're just rich they're just
this rich company that's pumping money
into the game division that's not
showing fruit and now we're seeing fruit
and especially with game pass it's
pretty
much 18 million it's not necessary man
it's really impressive the thing to me
that is most impressive is um
in one quarter they made
15 billion dollars in profit so that's
that they basically
copped two bethesda's right
two bethesda's they're seven points so
what i know what is a bethesda equal
[Laughter]
[Music]
look we got to put the buddy talk up but
um at the end of the day
it is interesting to me that in that's
one quarter
they bought two bethesda's in a sense
right so i just find it
humorous that people would say yo they
gotta recoup they got yo they get better
got to go all
joints because microsoft has to make
this money but i just find that
hilarious
so you know we'll see what happens with
that at the end of the day but um and
the last thing is um
as far as the whole the bigger picture
to marj's point right
you got the 18 million but then you
still got the what is it you know 100
you know 100 men gold
loot users overall xbox live so that's
still 82
that you know they want to convert right
that still has to be the goal we know
the staff fool
recently you know what i'm saying but
it's because they're looking at it like
yo
they want to convert these guys they
just got to figure out how to do it
they just don't need to strong-arm
people into jacking the price up
two times right guys they don't need to
strong-arm nobody
into it he's got to figure out a way
because that's the thing they've got
this tremendous growth they got 100
million 18 is great
but they really want that 18 to at least
like 50. they want to keep that
pushing you know what i'm saying so look
it's the other day it's good news
uh you love to hear the growth in the
industry especially for xbox the game
division because that was the room oh
they're not doing well
you know they're standing there so let's
see what's going on but we got to move
on because it's a lot of show
uh soft media mink
yeah uh yeah so the medium came out on
thursday this is the
fourth game from bluebird team the
developers of layers of fear
observer uh blair witch project and of
course the medium
um so it came out on game pass day one
um and i am enjoying it i i'm enjoying
it i
there's things about it that i wish were
different but i think as a call back to
old school resident evil
silent hill style games i think it does
an admirable job i enjoyed
the atmosphere that it presents the the
sort of uh
the everything about the atmosphere the
the the sound
the sort of landscape the uh the hotel
that you're in
um is very spooky um so
i i re i'm enjoying it the only things
that i don't like about it really
are the things that that are throwbacks
that i think
just needed to stay in the past i'm not
necessarily a fan
of the sort of the pre-canned camera
angles yeah
i don't think i don't think they they
needed to do that obviously
they did that for a reason right that's
the type of story they wanted to tell
and that's how they wanted to tell it
but i think um when when
kind of comparing it to something like
residual 2 remake and what they did to
make that game scary yeah and pull it
out of that sort of pre-canned camera
angle thing
um one thing they did was was put the
camera
like almost right behind the player
right so it's it's closing
so it's it but it's still third-person
camera but it's close enough
in that it feels claustrophobic yeah and
i
or or just make it first person right
obviously what they wanted to do with
the duality stuff they felt that this
was the way to go
right um but i think in total it it
slows down the game
in a way that just i for me kind of
takes away from it a little bit
that said story wise though i do i
i enjoy the story so far that they're
trying to tell uh it's gotten
kind of wild right now i hit a spot
that's gotten
a little bit crazy um and i'm enjoying
that the dual sort of world thing is
cool
uh the the the uh sort of land of the
dead part though
i feel in terms of the way it looks is a
little bit one note
and it's not super interesting um and
the mechanic about
of going back and forth between worlds
to me is cool
but it isn't like oh my god drop dead
like this is
the hottest thing game changer um but
all in all
i do enjoy the game i do feel that it is
in a lot of ways their most sort of
accessible game
um and it shows that they are improving
in terms of their storytelling
in terms of their production value for
sure um
so i think it's a it's a nice step
forward for bloober i i
you know there aren't many teams that
are just focusing on horror games and i
love horror games
so to see them kind of take a step
forward even if it's not as big of a
leap as i necessarily hoped it would be
right but uh i am happy to see that
there's forward movement and i am
enjoying it generally and i kind of
can't wait to see how this game ends
because i hit a point where the story
sort of
starts to kind of unravel a little bit
and show you what's really going on
and it's very cool very cool let me get
more bonds in here we got a man this is
we got we got pulling the home team
blooper
[Laughter]
i want to bring mods in because uh two
reasons one because um
obviously you know polish studio and the
fact that they just recently
um i saw you put the tweet out mods
where you were talking about how
they were able to recoup already
financially so just your thoughts about
that and then the game itself
yeah i was actually quite surprised that
you know like literally one day sales
you know covered all the production and
marketing costs right
and um so the article i i
i found was that was on um money
money.pl yeah it's
you know it's a polish site that deals
with uh you know that it's like for
investors and that kind of stuff right
sorry and so i was quite surprised that
that they made so much money like day
one right and
you know clearly they were talking about
the sales so i don't think
it it contains any money from microsoft
for
the game pass deal wow i mean they
haven't said anything
like specifically but i don't they were
talking to just
generally speaking generally sales yeah
that's the data is impressive right
because at the end of the day you would
assume
because it's game pass that it's like
why is king dancing
you would assume because let me play you
a polish tune
you because it was gay past that you
know that it would the revenue you know
that
or microsoft would have doesn't sell it
once it's engaged oh god
he got words on the street
yeah so yeah i mean well done bloomberg
basically right i mean
i mean that game is available on xbox on
pc
so um there's um you know other people
like it on steam as well uh you know
it's
good quite good reviews isn't it um yeah
as for the game
um i'm like two hours into the game so
not too far really
um i mean you know uh to i mean
the game mechanics is kind of like old
really yeah yeah
so i'm not really sure whether that's
really whether that was done on purpose
or not
but um you know could be it does feel
um you know first 15
20 minutes was kind of odd because i was
like what the hell am i
am i playing i mean the game looks good
and like i said the visuals are cool
um the animations are kind of stiff yes
so same facial animation that kind of
stuff
so that that feels a little bit off
because
like the graphics is very realistically
looking that kind of stuff
um so that but once you get used to that
and stuff right uh those technical kind
of things um
you know the game is actually pretty
cool and you know i like the
the the puzzles and you know the whole
you know dual
words and that kind of stuff and you
know it's um
it's um it's nothing really
revolutionary and that kind of stuff
right
and to be honest with you i would really
expect that for from
team like bloomberg right but um it's
cool
and another thing about this game is
that like it's
it's based in poland and offering real
places and uh historical things too
that's what's going to happen
how's the authenticity with like again
that hotel that they've renamed that's a
real life
yeah i mean this this this hotel
in i mean it's not in the same state as
in you know
not as devastated and stuff it's still
there it's still in krakow right
and it's actually it's it was uh it's
it's protected right now because it's
like
how do you call it people landmark yeah
something like that
yeah and so you know they can even
somebody invested some money into it and
it
literally looks the same um so
i mean there's a lot of polish kind of
um because
that hotel was in poland right
savage they invested their money
continued so
that hotel was built during like
communist
uh kind of times and that kind of stuff
so here's that kind of vibe to
it and and stuff and like you know
playing the game i found like you know
relics of that you know prl as we call
them like you know the good old poly
you know social you know the the
communist poland and
like you know there is the scene where
you you you have to
find a screwdriver yeah to open the
doors and that kind of stuff and
it's in the car oh sorry yeah that's a
clown no no but that's a classic
car yeah so yeah i mean
basically yeah exactly so it's like you
know we call them maluk right because
they were very small
compact rather cheap back in the days
they don't produce them
anymore anymore obviously so i like that
kind of things to find in the games
i mean warm right it made it yeah yeah
it's it's cool
um the only thing i was disappointed
with was the fact that there's no polish
um you know dialogues and that kind of
stuff voiceover
and but i read i read an article
that basically it you know they blame
covet
um because it's actually interesting
because they capture
the um motion capture yeah
was done by polish uh actors like real
actors
pretty good actors i might say right i
mean you know those names won't tell you
anything but like paul they they are
pretty known
okay they're good actors so it's kind of
um
so it's sad that that like despite the
fact they used them they
they couldn't do voiceovers or whatever
and and even said that
even even motion capture and english
you know voiceovers were done remotely
anyway so it was really difficult to do
um so yeah that's the so that's the
thing
but so far i really like the game i mean
obviously it's not
one of those you know super bangers and
that kind of stuff right but
it's nice cool little game 10 hours
apparently
you know it's not too long you know it's
you know i i played
like an hour today and it just came in
and that game kept
you know popping up the the the
achievements and stuff right so
yes no you made a good point before i
give it to guys um
that i forgot about that like i remember
them talking about the motion capture
but again you forget with the pen then
because that's one of my nitpicks and i
get to it when it's my turn but
you know that you start as you talked
about which is you know
i just felt it was a little off with the
sink
and the voice sometimes you know what
i'm saying like just slightly and it
just
it sometimes it broke my merger but i
forget you know what like
we had people on during the pandemic the
devs on the hardest thing to do during
the pandemic
is orchestra because music to get
everyone in the same room
yeah and motion capture mocap is the
hardest during the pandemic you're
supposed to socialize
so again it makes sense now based on
what you're saying
not that i'm excusing you know saying
but i'm just saying it does make sense
would you say because i'm like okay
that part threw me off a little bit but
let's get guys in man like what what's
up man like how you
feeling about the medium in general
what's what's your thoughts um my
thoughts are that xbox has no games
[Laughter]
so
no i'm playing i'm playing i haven't
actually played it so i can't really
talk about it
um and to be honest uh i see
christopher hart in the channel
you like the order 1886 conversation
so but i was going to say look there's
so much variety now on tap on game pass
i like
i haven't played it so i can't go ham on
it after people are talking about its
resolution
um on that point the con the game is
demanding even on a pc
analysis asap just i think he's he's
he scrapped that idea because he was a
bit late in the game couldn't get the
press copies in time because that takes
a lot of time to do yeah but he said his
he's got a 3090 with a 5950x jesus
and he and he said the pc performance is
an issue so
people getting excited about 900p
i mean next is actually doing really
well yeah you don't know about that
would be struggling on the ps4
i'm hearing the 2080 super that was
struggling to try to even attempt like
60.
so this is a demanding game i mean
christopher hart i'm about to destroy
you but don't worry about it
right now i'm just gathering strength
i'm turning into
[Music]
he did a really good you know review for
the game as well which i read
and it's i it's nice what i like about
it
is it's no it's a polish outfits in
poland it's something unique
so my buddy mads can experience the
source
but i mean it's not my type of obvious
i'll be honest it's not my type of game
but i would never try it i don't think
because i've spent so much time playing
multiplayer games
except for the fact that i definitely
will i'm downloading it now
why because of game pass
that's real that's real let's get the
supercharger there let's get at it
go on the second
[Music]
stitch with the five dollar super chat
uh manny said that it would take a few
years for microsoft to make that money
back from the bethesda deal and game
pass
said and game pass that hold my beard
then we got new cybot with the five
dollar super chat i'm not sure who is
reviewing the medium but to me it is a
solid 8.5
looks great plays good and the story is
compelling and scary
then we got corey hale with the 15 super
chat
down salute lords and chat was initially
disappointed in the medium with the lack
of action
uh thought i'd play for a couple minutes
and turn off but the story keeps me
intriguing that i want to see it through
yeah and i think that that's my thing
too like
i mean you're going in you know it's not
actually right it's not
there's no combat really um but the
story
you hear a point in the story because
the beginning is a really really a slow
burn right it's very much a slow burn
there's a point when when like i said
things start to unravel you start seeing
the story for what it is and
and why you are where you are and it's
like oh okay
i'm in now like i need to see this
through no doubt no doubt what else we
got
uh we got michael aka bedsides fine it's
the five dollar super tap
the creature that follows you is creepy
is this creepy man in the medium also
that soundtrack will draw you in when
the creature is present
good game in my book uh just uh fun
facts
who don't know this um the creatures is
voiced by troy baker
okay troy baker voices the creature so
yes
there will eventually be a game where
only troy baker voices
every character
[Music]
this in the chat as well um yeah you
play with headphones
yeah oh please headphones
yeah so what caught up all right cool
lord attic man did you try the medium
well yeah
played like an hour and a half of it and
it just wasn't for me and i turned it
off oh
bushes bushes
i just i just wasn't interested in the
story it wasn't it's just
the only thing that was interesting was
that the little spirit thing you meet
like
that's literally all like i didn't
really care for the
the environment you know it's just well
i knew it wasn't for me the moment the
game was exhibit
the game existed you knew it wasn't for
you
did you ever care for like the old rez
evils of silent hill did you ever
care for those i didn't really care for
the old silent hill i liked the old
resident evils but
i just i don't know i just didn't i
didn't like it but it's a it was of a
time and place like i love those games
too
but like going back to tank controls now
i'm like nah i'm good man
let me let me ask because this is a good
thing i was gonna ask that like what was
the immediate turn off was it is it the
lack of action
or just like graphically or like what
was it muting you like now this ain't it
i think it was just a story story didn't
grab me at all
like normally i i can do stuff that's
not
but i just didn't care about the story i
didn't care about the characters
i was just like you know and i got so
much stuff i i
i have in my backlog i'm like do i
really want to force myself to play this
and then and then i looked and i was
like no i don't know you said that
you're good
last question um were you ever a silent
hill
guy like i said are you a resident evil
guy i was a resident you wouldn't
okay
just trying to ask a question no doubt
lord
king you've been charging up
oh the music is interesting oh oh
all the things say says god bless you
god bless you we're on we're on a
wonderful sunday mm-hmm
we we are here yes and the medium has
released that that 28th
yo i couldn't all right so my level of
expectation for this game was uh pretty
pretty pretty pretty high
because after playing the blair witch i
was like damn man they they could have
hit it but they did and i was
i was drawn in to a lot of things of the
blair witch but
they never achieved what i wanted them
to achieve because of the limitations of
the xbox one
and then leading up to this game i saw
the dualities in the world that
exist and she's a medium for people that
don't understand the name medium and
what it means
it's uh somebody that can converse with
the the dead
you know so um and they are
powerful mediums actually see them
physically manifest within front of them
yes so to convey this to you in terms
they had to do it in the layman terms to
show you
we're going to uh have the scene at the
half top of the screen
and the other world at the bottom of the
screen and if she's interacting with the
spirit
the spirit is interacting with you but
she's doing the stuff
in real time in the real world so if
someone wants to see her
at that point in time that she's
interacting with said spirit
it will look like she's talking to
herself and she's crazy right
okay so now we got the gist of that down
pack
the technical limitations that they were
put under because of colbit or whatever
it's pretty daunting especially for a
title like this where you have to work
closely
with your compatriots now i'm not saying
that this
is any reason for any downfalls i
believe that is technically demanding
within itself let's let's let's tell the
truth and shame the devil this is not a
retrash
a rehash game that they can spice up
this is a
full new game that's only
released on the series s and series x
and
on the pc which is a platform for
microsoft okay
so this is a real next-gen game
not none of that re-trash stuff that's
going on let's talk about
the lineup next gen has started on the
28th
mm-hmm for all those people that was
able to get into this is what next year
you
financially the game
has achieved that the people have spoken
all right we didn't even get into game
pass uh uh
uh interaction so my level of
interaction with said game is through
game pass
right all right and only would be
through game pass now if i said to
purchase the game i would and i must
commend blue betaine for what they
gave for because i'm a silent hill lover
right i love silent hill so when
sovereign said he didn't like the tank
feelings
the feelings of that tank movement for
certain things
is necessary to induce the level of fear
right i was so afraid of certain things
and i'm pretty far in the game i'm
pretty sure
that i'm close to the end because i
found out a whole bunch of stuff
and i had to stop playing this morning i
was like i need sleep i need sleep
right i'm going to every corner of the
boat because you can get past certain
stuff without looking at things
but then there's certain rooms that you
must figure out certain stuff
yeah now i don't want to blow up
anything because it's story driven right
but the the technicalities of the game
the graphics the stuff that's going on
i'm i'm i broke immersion a lot of times
because of the frame pacing yeah
right and i i blame microsoft
oh all right i blame microsoft on
the fact that they didn't have the
proper sdks and gdks out
to uh give these developers all that
they need
at this period of time this is where
sony actually shines
okay right they use old tools on the old
console
to give it to the new developers so they
was using old stuff to get it you know
running pretty good
so that's that's nice it's the old
console this is new stuff microsoft had
to wait until amd
had the proper tools out and announced
certain things that would be available
so
things weren't really readily available
for it now i believe patches are
incoming
for this game to keep it running at a
stable resolution
and a stable frame rate now the
resolution drops somebody said 900p
you wouldn't know because your tv is off
the floor oh my god
i'm going to tell you this right me
and and this is when i'm going to force
on you
me i'm going to floss on you right now
me and my 10k
88 inch samsung television that i'm
watching on
that i can see more because my view is
larger than yours
um you can just see more average stuff
i mean i saw i saw texture popping
when it was going to certain things but
not as bad as
last generation you know i i'm seeing
the ssd
in effect and i'm noticing it now like
why ssd is necessary
i can't see any perceivable load times
right so i'm playing the game i don't
see any perceivable low times when i'm
going from room to room or section to
section
cut scenes are beautifully done now the
animation is a little bit stiff
does it feel like a throwback game hell
yes it does
but does it capture that horror feel yes
it does
right is the story narrative fantastic
this is the first game
and you know i don't do this i don't
pick up stuff and read it yeah
i'm reading every audio logs are pretty
strong i do i do feel that
so okay i have my headset be where the
whole budget went to
pretty much pretty much i mean it's not
for you
right so i had my headset on and my
daughter sent me i had the music on
right
and my daughter wasn't all that
my daughter's watching me play the game
and
she's she's totally invested so my dog
is sitting there
it's a part where you're going to get to
a canine right and the canine
is going to be making weird noises
my dog oh here stood up on her back
faced the television and was like what
the hell is going on with this dog
and then she went to the sound bar to
like you know
are you okay like you didn't need any
help
the dog was listening to today the sound
the sound was that amazing it affected
the pooch
i'm like the ambient sound the headset i
had on it was beautiful the feeling the
vibrations
everything that you want from a silent
hill has that has been absent
because konami felt that they don't want
to give it to us probably a reason it's
been absent to be honest
well i mean but you know millions of
other people don't agree with you
i'm just saying but millions of people
have tried it i mean you you tried it
you didn't like it all right god bless
say less
why you gotta say what
someone for the individuals that do
that are in the know that actually stuck
around and actually played a fantastic
wonderful game
that is actually the start of next-gen
excuse you
um you have you have picked the winner
because when you when you get to the end
and you i thought i knew something
i pretty much thought i had it down pack
i thought i had the story figured out
to get to the part where i was at
flipped it i sat there with a little
tear in my eye like are you serious
um i heard some serious content
no serious issues i i like that i like i
like people that aren't afraid
and shout out to bluebertine for not
being afraid to tackle
an issue that is prevalent in our
society that nobody wants to talk about
so there's a message okay yeah it's a
huge message and it also
shows the demon with this side a lot of
you
this game is unapologetically unafraid
to attack an issue when you get to the
crux of it when you when you get to the
bottom line
you're going to be like man i didn't
even believe i didn't think they would
go
there to the level of psychosis popping
bottles from shout out to
the gamer.net who reviewed the game gave
it a 9.1
you know i give it the same i give it
the same i walk away the technical
issues
don't distract so much from it but it is
a distraction
and i do hope they do release a patch to
fix and
even certain things out because i'm
noticing graphic remember before like
we used to get clipping in games yeah
yeah and stuff like that and
we would see those technical problems we
don't see that now now these
little weird discoloration boxes will
pop up and i'm like what the hell is
this
yeah i'm like is this the 900 p that
there was
[Laughter]
but it it'll pop up and it it'd do that
and
um i'm just really pleased that they
didn't launch the game
i'm glad it's a success and on a
successful platform
that millions 18 plus million people get
a chance to try
and it's not for everyone it may not be
for you but uh
it's it was for me and i enjoy it and
i can't wait for card to get to a
certain point because on clay avenue
we used to play manhunt at night like
when the parents were going
back to the next level but we was in
that house
and it got so scary at times with
certain things that i would do
and and i would walk around the house in
the dark trying to figure out what it
was to get a scream out and i would be
like all i want is your soul
do y'all remember remember the house on
the corner cog oh look
the house in the corner they had like
the the the ivy sort of thing
growing up mm-hmm she's a nice lady too
yeah she's that house scared the hell
out of us
yeah what well yo let me let me jump in
um yeah
now i'm glad you said that kid because
i'm gonna fry you making me want to
stick with it because i'm in like the
mod stage well i'm like
two and a half maybe where did you make
it to i'm in the hotel you know
okay okay yeah i've been on yet yeah so
i'm not here you know it's in the right
mindset
look look i mean look that's what i'm
gonna say though um to saul's point
like the writing and the voice acting is
really good
i'm very early i like the atmosphere the
atmosphere it's popping like i do like
that
shout out to bonds i like the real
polish settings you know what i'm saying
i get a little history you know while
i'm learning and reading stuff that was
cool the audio
shout out just because he's polish yeah
we got to shout that out
[Laughter]
i'm listening i'm i am team poland i
feel like that the developers are coming
up every time i go to um
like the shows the conventions the taxes
and stuff like that there is a rise you
know what i'm saying
in the development community and i
always want to salute man
you know what's this it's like i love it
which is quite surprising to be honest
with you because 20 years ago there was
hardly any developers and
you know there was no money in in that
here in poland so
yeah that's that's quite surprising i'd
like to see that and that's wicked
and you guys make me want to play the
medium really bad kingdom good
facts yeah king definitely sold it
because i didn't know it
i didn't know it went there i heard
rumblings you know what i'm saying but
um
look the character dialogue i get her i
actually like her self dialogue as she's
figuring things out
and she talks to herself like okay and
that keeps me in it and
and clearly this her being a medium is
something she's dealt with
her entire life you know i'm saying it's
something that she feels like yo people
didn't understand
and that's where i'm at the third fruit
guy yeah
no sorry i'm so stupid that i didn't
realize the name medium until king david
look the 30 phrase didn't bother me as
much because that style of game i mean
it's
it's slow paced it's fixed camera angles
that didn't bother me okay and
because it's a slow investigative nature
kind of pick up the pieces
this goes there that kind of thing i get
it i still want the no
shooting thing i didn't bother me the
thing
i actually like the the little spirit
focused thing and yeah
i'm saying that's dope the thing again i
i got a nitpick the reason why i got a
nitpick is cause i look at this game
and it's like it could be flawless but
it's just this blemish that keeps
throwing in my
face with the animations and and the
thing
it breaks my emergency because i'm like
damn they they could have had one
that was flawless you know what i'm
saying and i don't know if it's
if it's colvid i don't know if you know
because of the motion cap situation
but it just bothers me did you see the
motion capture
uh contraption stuff yes i did yeah
i mean i i'm i'm sorry i don't mean to
jump into your job yeah
and i don't mean to take away from them
they did it in my mind he just wants to
take away from me
no no they did it in the crib
bro they literally i saw a dude climbing
over a box
in the basement and i said you got this
game out yeah
yeah you made it shout out to them for
whatever they didn't do it i just
wish the situation was different because
with a little bit more polish
with a little bit more animation you
know what i'm saying
this could have been because we would
have just been talking about how amazing
it looked
and then get wrapped in but now i'm
wrapped in and i'm like oh my
favorite movie oh her jacket did this
you know like it was like oh eddie just
sounds like an average game to me
i don't like your face anyway
is that that is going to track certain
people like an addict you know
from from missing out on something that
king is like
kid is right like i don't know i'm gonna
be real with you addict i thought i was
like
this game probably mid people
hyping it up i'll see you know what i
mean
the mechanic thing is cool the reality
thing is cool
the way they do it and gets off like it
it's really done well
all of that all of that stuff the game
does well what it's supposed to
what this type of game is supposed to do
well right i mean listen
none of these games you go back to any
of these games with tank controls and
fixed camera angles silent hills
resident evil
nobody's ever talking about the gameplay
right right they're talking about
the scenarios that they find themselves
right the atmosphere the overall story
arc especially silent hill like right
when you talk about the themes that are
in this game
i immediately think about silent hill 2.
right yeah violent hill 2 when you get
to the end of silent hill 2 when you
realize
what the crux of that story is you're
like oh my god
what what have i done yes i can tell
this is going and shout out to
manchester chat because
i do feel where the energy is got done
well
is the environment you you feel
a certain thing when you get into the
journey so that's all it is because it's
like it's a shame because of
that animation stuff or whatever and
because of the fixed camera angles
you know put it this way if this was the
traditional
over the shoulder third person i'm
telling a lot of people ain't going to
complain as much and they would deal
with it they wouldn't have the graphical
issues that's pretty much what i had to
say yeah and and i think this game is
more
it's more about suspense than it is
you're horror this is psychological
thriller
that's why i don't like you yeah and i
get it i completely understand it it's
not going to be for everybody
this is not going to be everybody but
for those who like psychological
thrillers
this is going to capture and i know what
it reminded me of what he provided
it reminded like the way they man
i'm tr i'm just trying to time this i
don't want to talk about it
but the game's not bad it's something
like
i i was in a party yesterday and someone
said i'm going to try medium because i
have game pads like that's what this
is about like you know a game like
medium
it probably would have did okay but it
would have flopped in the end
like but because people can get their
hands on it and because
you know the the horror community is
like pretty much grabbing anything they
can
right it's good well and i hope the game
does well because i see
potential in the studio right but put it
this way put it this way
it's one of those situations where i'm
hoping
there's a there's a medium too yeah i
don't think so
oh based on the story so you know what
they do they do a lot of one-off stuff
too
yeah based on the story okay i mean
maybe in the world
okay yeah maybe you know maybe they do
this thing and it's like uh right
this is this person something yeah yeah
i say this i say this to say the attic
right
you already was put off from the game
before you got to it right right
where i was intrigued by the game
literally from the inception of it right
because i i'm into that type of stuff
and i'm not taking anything away from
you
but you you mentioned that somebody was
inside uh
game chat and they said they're gonna
try because it was there and that you
feel that it would normally flop without
game pass
and i feel that to be true king that
you're supposed to watch it to the very
end and there's also an
after credit seat okay i will i will
okay i'm gonna finish it up today maybe
maybe thanos will show up and snap this
game good oh my god
i'm saying that no i'm just playing i i
don't really feel like this you guys
that's good
no no i don't like the game
this is a game that that i think you're
demon souls dude
okay how does that mean anything no okay
let me say this
because i gotta hear this region when
you was playing sin
i was super intrigued but i know it
wasn't for me
right when it came to game pass i tried
it
and i was like yeah i'm not i'm this is
not for me
but it literally resonated with you to
the point where you
beat the demo in a guy's face right it
was
your joy he didn't do it so i i really
respect that and i really like the fact
that game pass and
y'all think i cap for game pass i do so
what
it was in game pass i tried it and i
literally tried it the same day it came
out with the same level of anticipation
then let me see if it sticks with me now
that i'm in my own environment to try it
out
but the ability to try a game that you
would not
normally plunk down 70 bucks this is 70
bucks here guys
i think i think when it comes to this if
anything this screams like
anything that this screams is xbox is
trying to be diverse with game pass
they're trying to give people whatever
they want like
you know this might not necessarily
agree to me when starfield drops at the
end of the year that's probably not
going to agree to both of
you but it's going to agree to me yeah
i'm in on that but
i mean i think but just like you said i
think the the diversity that game pass
allows for allows that you know
a minus b tier game to exist again in a
world where
that died like when the original thq
died
the b tier game a lot of which were very
good games
died along with it not to cut yourself
the
walking simulator we've seen we've seen
telltale die
yeah we've seen these genres even and
don't get me wrong
so many guys in the reaction that like i
expected a different type of game with
this oh okay it's not the game
because i i i love those type of games
but this one is just it just
i played like an hour of it i was like
check this part out
right it's a single player
yeah story driven it's we we're not
going to do that
it's a single player story driven
next-gen game it's the new ip
[Laughter]
you don't need it anymore you have it
you go you got you want it done
that's not it i want them to purchase
blue
team because if you compare blue
boutique i think that
would be good with that other company i
mean that other development houses that
they purchased within the
zenimax deal that does uh the the
what is that game compulsion the other
scary game that they
that they make the evil within even yes
if you can um like have one year
something from blue team one year from
the evil within
developers to keep that that b level
cause
some dudes love b-movies yeah yeah you
know and i'm one of those weirdo dudes
that like d
movies yeah you know i mean is it try is
it is
it something that you can try yeah am i
telling you sony dude so this is the
reason for you to
run over and cross the street and
purchase no i mean if you want some of
the next gen
experience you can do that but um what i
am saying
to you is the reason why game pass is
so inviting mm-hmm i would have never
purchased this game
in fact exactly and without game pass
like let's say this game this game comes
out everywhere
right a game like this probably straight
up dies on the playstation that's all
just about to say that my point was
i'm a super detroit becomes human fan
i love that game you know what i'm
saying and it's like
necessarily knocking out the box you
know what i'm saying and then we saw it
you know go to all the platforms and
stuff like that
so waiting for it to come the game pass
wow i'm waiting for whatever you know
i'm saying like
it's just bc right now yeah
that it's a beautiful game it's well and
again it fits that
walking simulated choice mode i mean
it's a little different from medium but
not harder but
that that's the thing and it's cool to
see a game like this
regardless of how the masses feel that's
not for everybody
but still do successful recoup course do
all this stuff
that definitely would not have happened
that that means to me that needs to
happen
we have to find we have to have again
that this platform
allows for that type of game to come
back in a way that it hadn't been it
didn't have a place anymore
and then everybody's looking at you know
where the big bang is all the time like
you're not going to get triple a bangers
all the time yeah that's all that's
awesome
i've heard anyone talk about that in
detail about
game pass facilitating that kind of
double a
title more because everyone thinks
people see it from the negative and like
oh yeah it's going to be
game pass fodder or something right
but but that's the thing like that's
that's a dumb argument through it right
because let's say
let's say on the playstation platform
right playstation my
that's my platform for their first party
stuff meaning
that there are long stretches of time
when they don't have a brand new banger
out
that i'm not playing that console
there's just i don't have much
intermediary stuff right
right and you know and then the small
stuff that does come out there
it doesn't get supported by that
community the way it would on a game
pass
on the xbox live for instance this this
month and games were in in their ps plus
concrete genie concrete gm came out
and they you know the ps faithful sort
of forgot about it
it didn't do well but it was it was
published by sony
it would it was sort of brought to the
forefront by them
and it was sort of ignored because it
didn't fit you know that sort of
that archetype of what a sony sort of
first party banger is
right and it's in it and it's not fair
it's not necessarily like it there needs
to be a space on both of these consoles
where this type of game can exist
and thrive because that again it just it
brings up everybody to
allow these games to have an audience
and actually
mobilizing the industry you make a
really good point like you know how i
mentioned with the playstation we had a
breadth of games from double a
studios you have your games like
vigilante i don't know if you guys
remember
oh man yeah of course yeah i love that
stuff but you can't see that like a
twisted metal black even the new twisted
metal wouldn't be
apparently yeah it was on the
playstation side ever since
the the big name like i will say ps3
forward right you started at you started
getting these
these these big sort of huge titles the
uncharteds and stuff like that
but on ps1 and ps2 there was plenty of
shovelware that i loved
like it was like you said vigilante ate
a whole bunch of like side little
third-party stuff that
they didn't have a lot of name
recognition but were fun games
that space just doesn't exist there
anymore yeah no good points man all
around
i know we beat this topic to death but
um look good to see
them doing well for me i'm doing well
again and uh the success of the studio
and uh see what we got more from bloop
in the future we got to move on
attic let's wrap this thing up man you
bleeding edge
what's going on yeah they say
[Laughter]
but they that game i mean i'm a massive
fan of that kind of
title just felt so short
of fundamental things it's not
surprising that they
uh they've re-prioritized ninja theory
onto a bigger bigger
better things man they can't be dragging
down or devoting
resources to a game that i'm pretty sure
most people were surprised they were
still dividing
resources so far officially looks like
yeah they said they shut down
development on a bleeding edge you say
studios now focused on
hellblade sequel and again the uh
project mar the other the other projects
um look i'll jump in because i wanted to
talk about this you know i do feel
from a man's you know saying because my
man's he's riding for this game like hey
let god let me let me play the picture
real quick like
me and solve we're at e3 you know what i
said
we got to go online for it and then
he um caught the the developer the uh
shout out to
ronnie shot the right ronnie yeah you
know
she's on the line he's like yo yo get on
it
and i'm all right co-host with cole
moe's he right he right you know what
i'm saying so i had to get into my
profession now we got the mic we gotta
pop it and it was so cool to see because
at the time
it was one of those things where it was
like yo microsoft's making them do it
remember that that was like the yeah
they got to talk at the time right but
see this is a problem with microsoft get
a whole
they foster them and she was like no no
we had this in the back burner
and it was just a unique concept so me
and solving our interview bag
it was a fun it was a fun time so it was
cool to see so i am saffron because i
know
he was pulling for this project and um
you know
just my only concerns was the melee
multiplayer aspect you know i'm saying i
didn't know how that was going to flow
that i got to be real you know the
reason why they didn't get cog
is because i just wasn't a fear of the
the fan of the character designs
i felt like they didn't have memorable
kind of like even though i i'll be
clowning on overwatch i can't in front
of overwatch characters
like overwatch characters you want to
play as they're reality
yeah like they got the thing so i just
felt that was the thing and then and
then to um alex point he got first of
all
subscribe to my man channel being mad
because he's got an amazing video that
should have been doing what way about on
this game on the subject
about it and um about the whole
situation because
he made it beautifully clear no road map
when's the content coming so it's like
all these little mishaps and
it was just you know and it's sad
because we love lindsay dairy you know
what i'm saying
and um you know but definitely it's sad
to see them go
with this and then you know obviously
you're gonna switch gear but now i got
to be messy
that got to be messy now i get to be
saucy now
for all you xbox game studio
fans who was coming from my neck saying
obsidian in the goat it's ninja theory
yeah hold this l because i told y'all
this wasn't it and even though i don't
even like grounded
she was successful exactly grounded and
popping even though i don't like ground
dude
so i want like a year ground be
knees for all the ninja theory dude
where you at dizzy let me look for you
in the chat
jesse all you do is popping off talking
about they the best
new acquisition hold that hold this one
and fire up that grounding when you get
a chance i'll be your message i'll be a
messenger
or all jokes to sell jokes aside you
don't say it like you know you never
want to see that happen
ninja terry's still popping they got
hellblade too they got project mara it's
still it's still good but just don't
come for the goat
you know what what you're saying is you
two for two yeah
one for one exactly when you come
forward
actually no they're not even one for one
they they um
owen one listen there's only one go
acquisition here when it comes to the
new studios you know
yeah that's cinematic
listen they ain't making a game yet dave
holla at me
highlight the goats the obsidian goats
all i gotta do is just put a uh
jpeg up yeah we already know elders
i want to carry on hold on
let me let me talk about talk this is my
time
[Laughter]
it's a king trying to come for me we all
know the best
fallout was that new vegas made by the
ghosts
thank you thank you don't worry about
what i did
[Laughter]
don't worry about what watch what
just a little bit just a little bit it
was a fun time it was saluted
but no i'm finished i yeah my balls so
is that the only one you know i got my
boss i'm good out of the world just
just say what i want to say yes yes
please okay cool
all right um so i didn't think microsoft
showed it in proper light
all right i was i was standing there
with the the head of ninja theory nina
christensen
and yeah so what i'm dropping oh yeah
yeah he was with the studio yeah you
know louise
and we were talking about you were
schmoozing kicking the kickless schmoozy
licking
i see you
[Music]
you know i told i said i didn't i didn't
think because actually when i did get a
chance to see
the actual demo i thought the demo
looked better than the trailers that
they showed
now the characters um i i'm not going
over [ __ ]
the character design to me on the
characters were great but
like cog is saying they didn't have
personality to flow and i don't think
the game
really had the legs uh that it needed
after playing the game i felt that like
you were saying the melee combat of it
took away from the game that's with a
few i think if they was having
more range attacks and they changed it
up they wanted to be so
different from overwatch in these games
that they were completely different and
you didn't take the successful nature
of overwatch except for the character
designs
and you know attic attic tried a lot
you know with the game to push the game
to be honest with you um
the game really wasn't for me i don't
play overwatch
and i know it's a very hard genre
to be successful in uh noted by guys
guys
guys saying making a multiplayer game
see the trap
and being successful with it is hard as
hell
and i i always said it and y'all can go
back to my old words
i thought this was somebody's passion
project that microsoft said okay fine
you can put it out but whatever
um that's exactly what it was but
it's absolutely i mean when we talked to
ronnie tucker she said she was like
it's it's a small team yeah when we
remember they had just
recently sort of been purchased by
markets they were just purchased yeah
so and she said she said look we this
was on the table
and they could have easily been like no
walk away from that
and they let us do it yes so i mean that
that was the extent of it so
if it had blown up sure i i'm 100 sure
that it would have been
they would have dedicated more resources
to it and would not but like you were
saying
um it is very difficult to compete
in an arena with overwatch like hero
shooters i think are even more difficult
than just
your standard one of the real
multiplayer shooters just because the
the characters have to be very special
they have that person
like you said and the powers that they
utilize in terms
of like a hero shooter is different in
that everybody has a role right on the
battlefield
right and the ones that do that
do it very well like you know r.i.p
battleborn right
and yeah and and look what's look who's
been successful right
obviously overwatch apex they've managed
to give you
the hero shooter slash regular shooter
all-in-one um and that's pretty much
it when you talk when you talk about
that so paladin's yeah
now that it's actually getting traction
now so it is that thing where it was
very difficult to me
i thought it might be successful just
because uh hand-to-hand combat is the
ninja theory thing right so but upon
playing it
it still had those sort of the things
it had those things has those things
that hero shooters need whereas like
holding down positions and stuff like
that i'm like this doesn't feel
conducive
to hand-to-hand combat when you're
talking about i have to hold down this
area
i got it it's getting saucy with dizzy
hold on he
dizzy with a final super chat he said
ninja theory makes their own tech
what's the tech obsidian makes they do
they do good with other people's crayons
got your car
what a good detective for bleeding is
that that technique previously they
can't make their own ground
exactly clearly somebody else's
yeah they need to use someone else they
were so far in the bushes and still the
verdict is out on that apartment game
because i'm gonna call it the apartment
game y'all know unreal
project borrower in the apartment the
jury is still
right now you're very in the bushes
you're very shaky
to be talking to be talking to goats you
got a lot of flaws in your game right
now
yeah that's a ninja theory i i love
ninja theory but they've always been on
the front and they never
really got in the the the sort of rep
they deserve
but i mean heavily sword enslaved is a
fantastic game having this sword for
for like kind of a launch ps3 game was
was fantastic
dmc always gets shut down because it's
like oh it's not
but in terms of action yeah i don't like
crackhead dante but
action was fantastic and i think i think
when it comes to that it just there's
just a couple key things that they
messed up on
the the speed of the game i don't think
was an issue it was the characters
abilities that made the speed of the
game bad
yeah i i believe the the map design was
it wasn't horrible but definitely for
something like that
that's a melee focus game they should
add more interactions to
encourage close quarters yeah like you
know bridges
et cetera et cetera uh you know i feel
like
they dropped the ball with the
characters in general it's not
necessarily that the characters weren't
interesting you didn't know anything
about them
yeah they had no story to in-depth into
characters at all
none of the characters actual abilities
really like a lot of them stand out yeah
in overwatch you know you've got
characters that their abilities
complement each other
yes that didn't happen in bleeding
yeah they needed more of that like
overwatch
was the perfect layout of how you show
promote yes and play a game such as a
hero shooter yeah absolutely
and i i just feel like personally like i
feel like microsoft failed this i feel
like ninja theory failed this like
because they get the potential was there
it's just
i feel like after the initial launch and
then they started getting to the
bethesda purchase they started getting
to the grounded
they're like yeah that can go yeah we
don't need that anymore shout out today
okay and it just you know it gives me
a concept it's like do i do i invest in
ground
if grounded drops below a certain
engagement are they gonna cancel that
like but our engagement is super tough
so
i mean that was ours
i'm a fan boy i'm only fanboying what
i'm saying
i'm using wii i'm using our engagements
i want microsoft to support something i
don't want microsoft to
a little bit different if this is like
three years
with bleeding edge and it's like look
we're not going nowhere like how you
gonna let
a game come out and you give it a year
give it a year to capitalize
in an already saturated market and like
you gave c
thieves like two years off from nothing
but the difference is the diversity in
the studios you know i'm saying
obsidian can do the single player and
the multiplayer some people just good at
what they
do but
it's funny he says that but it's true i
mean i think they're focusing
now on what they're good
[Music]
like to me that's the exact reason
right you know ground it's like look
we're putting resources to this third
project that you guys are doing it's not
really doing
the kids out here popping it's like but
you know
i hundred like just go over there and
help her help blake too we need more
over there can i finish my statement
without you getting blessed for me for
no reason like you can be messy
after i'm being missed
there is a way that we do things here
yes come on you're supposed to be on the
other side
we need you to be the host we can't let
[Laughter]
like when it comes to cts they're like
okay we got um
we got sea of thieves rare we got c
thieves and we got um
what's that other one what's the
other game they're working on the other
game oh the uh ever wild everywhere
so like okay they're like cds go go to
everyone like they're not going to do
that because
see thieves is making two good games but
when it comes to ninja theater they're
like look groud is falling
falling below our throats don't stay
grounded
bleeding edges falling below our
threshold we don't believe in this
anymore
but people are hyping up hellblade go
over there to help like right
yeah and i feel like that they
sacrificed one arm
to make the bigger arm stronger yeah
more broadly more like on the other side
i can't go off with that with that
passion
at the end of the day if it's a passion
project don't give it a year to be a
passion project
like it's like you literally gave them a
year in a pandemic
pandemic it came out before but they
can't really do a full year of
development when they're working from
home
like i mean like i literally gave them
no chance
no i mean i hear that i hear that but at
the same time it's like
they have the boon of game pass right so
nobody's nobody's paying for this
uh separately right you have an install
base of
at that point i don't know how many
million it was at that point um
and it if nobody now i would say this
microsoft did a very bad job of putting
that game
about putting that game up to the
forefront right they didn't do that
after that first release the initial
release whatever it was
they didn't talk about that game that
game was never put to the forefront
there was never were there any sort of
dlc drops like they dropped talking to
hell
they dropped the character that was
initially put into the uh into the game
uh he was pretty much like he wasn't
finished at launch and then they dropped
another character after that they
dropped like a map or two and then
you know i knew it was over because i
played bleeding edge in a couple months
and i went looked at their website
and they ain't updated it's just like
the like the middle of last year
i was like yeah it's a wrap you can ask
you can ask a kid
yeah do you think the gameplay core that
was there could have been
changed or evolved in a way that may
would make it competitive with the
overwatches of the world
there's certain characters that need to
to be buffed let's
get off his boss man yeah that's right
everyone has interrupted this yeah
interrupted
no no guys please go go ahead no no no
no
brother you got some stuff you want to
say now please no i think
you give too much credit to leading edge
it was immediately apparent this game
was not going to last there were
fundamental problems even with the
format of the game
in terms of its mechanics of it was a
visual mess in terms of the ui
you can distinguish your friends between
your enemies even until
the current varying errors i'm like well
what am i looking at
all i'm looking at are like the health
bars of people it's not truly a melee
game because you can do distant
firing these little chipping away the
shots are
like why is he it was like that wasn't
what you promised the characters weren't
compelling
the game as soon as it came out i think
the vast majority of people knew right
this doesn't really have that much
potential the die hard stuck
by it where sea of thieves for instance
that the fun factor was there
no
listen i don't play those games and that
first month on
right there was nothing more fun than
the effort
of of of boarding somebody's [ __ ]
stealing all of this stuff yes like that
was that was the game
if a game is put out it is put out to
succeed
right i'm not having this microsoft put
that out to fail because you know what
that
encourages you to say this i encourage
you know that
i'm saying from the fan base like that
encourages this this
nonsense narrative going around that
that they put games in the game pass
just because
it's a game but that but that was that
game that was a game that they put out
to succeed on its own
steam they put that game out and gave it
a year
in a pandemic we can't use pad now we
can't use pandemic
we can't that game was 2019. that's what
he was saying
for the money microsoft say yo go ahead
they have 10 people working on that in a
pandemic and then it shows
everyone can use pandemic by bleeding it
guys because it came out before the pain
it's like you have to put content out to
continue to give people awesomeness now
you want to say
content after polishing just because
it's like me it was it was a dead game
it came out it was dead
you type in sea of thieves captain look
it's got so many
viral moments the game is actually fun
who tells us that's what i was just
about to say yeah straight facebook oh
got a bunch of people capping on a game
they even played
i played cfd did you talk about no i
know i talked about bleeding yet i
played it it wasn't fun
you've got to accept that people felt it
wasn't
fun regardless the resource if the game
is fun
people going to stick with it that's
just i do i do
that obviously other people felt the
same because they would have stayed with
it
i tell you from from from that uh e3
demo that we played we were there for
like a good 45 minutes
um and you know you try to be you try to
be professional you try to be nice
and it it there was a certain level of
polish to it
but i think all the things that gas
talked about were evident there
right and it was still it wasn't out yet
it was early but at the end of the day
when you look at it from a core design
perspective
it was lacking the things that were
going to make it that hit
that it needed to be out of the gate
because those games for the most part
unless you have epic money or you're
willing to invest epic money
they kind of they have to survive on
their own steve in the beginning you're
not going to keep putting money into
something you're not 100 sure it's going
to be great
right yeah 100 and overwatch you talk
about overwatch overwatch was a 60
game when it came out you paid for that
game at the end of the day you don't
have to spend like did you say you don't
just spend thousands of hours into
something to realize something is fun
like that's literally it it's gonna
capture you or it's not
that's all i was trying to say and i'm
not trying to be disrespectful at the
end of the day
yeah you don't want to see nothing go
away i'm just not feeling that all this
you know everyone everything else can be
used the pandemic man but bleeding edges
it's the timeline it's the time it came
out last year
like it came out march of last year
okay it came out officially march of
last year yes
we saw it e3 2019. that's because it
wasn't out we went in june and
it didn't come out the same year it was
delayed the development cycle was way
before that that's what i've got to say
the game was in creation
way before that they didn't just start
creating the game after we saw it and
then
come on that's what i'm trying to say
the pandemic did not affect them in that
manner the pandemic would affect
i'm gonna give it back to you guys the
pandemic would affect
future content i'd give you that yeah
i'm with you on that but
the game itself the core base no that
wasn't affected that i mean yeah
because you talk about they had two two
dlc drops or whatever during the course
of that year
um you would think that their plan
with that game having shown in 2019
would have been
they would have had a a lot longer sort
of game plan for this game
and it doesn't seem like they did it
just doesn't seem like they did
not that they weren't able to release
this stuff but there was ten people
working on it at the junk
ten people
[Music]
because i think the dev team itself was
how big right the dev team
so passion project guys i'm sorry we
keep interrupting you i'm sorry about
the team no no it's okay i mean it shows
that it looks like a free-to-play game i
really wanted to like it i was excited
about it
i was defending it before it was coming
me out i was like hey man i'd love ninja
there was a crowd that you know the sony
crowd was like oh well look at this you
buy new
theory and he stopped making enforcing
them yeah
yeah and that was just like me there was
this was in the works before they even
bought them
um and it was a passion project and it's
just it was just not
good enough the game was not good enough
if they were going to support it through
the pandemic
it would need a complete foundational
upheaval and a complete transformation
beyond recognition
to be successful and just leading edge
was not fair man
it's by far by a big big big margin man
not in the middle mods i'm sorry we
didn't get your thoughts on bleeding
edge at all
sorry inking yeah no worries i mean
um i i wasn't really a big fan of that
game
um and that was ever since i first saw
it um
actually you know the you know at e3
like
a year over a year ago really um
i don't really play that kind of games
because if anything i i prefer like
appropriate shooters that rather than
melee
any kind of games uh so like for honor
and
and that kind of games are not really
for me or to be honest with you like um
so i j like my personal opinion right of
course
but um i didn't like the you know the
characters
and and the stuff so i played it a
little bit
you know and when it was still in beta
and stuff
i didn't really enjoy it and to be
honest with you i didn't even play that
like uh you know the game when it was
like when it like properly launched you
know even by a guy in game pass i just
wasn't really you know interested but um
on the topic of whether they still
should still support it or not
i mean i mean microsoft is a very
um you know number um kind of driven
right um company right so you know they
clearly saw that that
that it was pointless to support this
game i guess and
and stuff like i don't know how many
people still you know played that game
and stuff right you know
but i would imagine that if people were
still interested in stuff they would
still support it and
and stuff right but i mean you know
ninja theory i mean they were never
really i mean
other than um what was this uh co-op
kind of game
on on ogx box uh kung fu fighter or no
was it kung fu kung fu chaos that was
yeah that was
chaos yeah yeah so i think but that
wasn't really a re
was it a multiplayer game no that was
like a coke
all right okay so because i wanted to
say that they they don't really have
much
to do with the multiplayer games okay so
i would i would like them
but you know for the most part like no
they they focus you know they
at least they used to focus more on like
a story story driven
kind of games like enslaved and that
kind of guy
games right this um as
uh what's the name of the this
playstation 3 exclusive
heavenly sword exactly that kind of game
so you know i would expect
games like that from them not like uh
these multiplayer kind of games so
you know i i to be honest with you i
really do hope that they stick to
project mara you know hellblade 2 type
of games and that kind of stuff these
kind of experiences
um and leave you know multiplayer kind
of driven kind of games to other teams i
guess
um um so i mean i'm not really going to
cry for
you know um really because of that but
um yeah yeah so
we've probably talked about bleeding
edge more than one two yeah we
definitely this
this bit crazy king i'm sorry brother i
didn't get your joint we got anything we
gotta roll
no i just feel that it sucks that um
this is the fate of the game that
everybody was uh saying was doomed to
fail from the beginning
you know um i just thought from
the beginning it was uh mishandled you
know
when i say that and i'm i'm laying uh
the blame at microsoft
be honest with you okay because uh if
this is your
first title from your newly acquired
acquisition
i think you should have just polished it
up to the point where it actually
reflected what was going on in the
marketplace
to be honest with you um you should have
had to focus test it
a little bit that's all i was saying is
they put it out to die they given no
support they didn't give
no money behind it it still had the
exact same amount of people
pre that it had posts like
you're right like like i told you you
were right
um like and a lot of dudes don't think
that i call microsoft out on certain
things i do
i think this was a one-off when it came
to okay we'll purchase you here's your
passion project
we'll give you the platform that's how i
look at that i swim from
the sink or swim and i don't think that
was right i think that you
uh if you if you make an agreement you
know you're going
a full you know wholeheartedly uh double
the team
you know at least at least double the
team for these guys give them the level
of
of support that they needed to make it a
thing but
then again at that point in time i don't
think
game pass was actually i think the
vision changed in game pass
when before that game was launched i
think if the game was launched now in
game pass
they were to give a whole lot more
support uh going forward because at that
point in time when game pass was
was uh the game was coming inside game
pass a game pass was creeping to those
numbers
now that the numbers that it achieved
now i think they understand the
viability of a game of this nature
and being that it had so it fell so far
it they can't revive it right you know
type of thing
it's a ready flat line to be honest with
you so if it will launch
now in game pass i think the thought
pattern behind to be honest with you
king i don't even agree with that
because ubisoft has
revived completely dead games like they
didn't even try
you know what you you you could be
completely right like
but also to your same point they said
that we're not going to
continue to fund this project while
you're working on this project that we
need to be a hit right you know um we
gave you the opportunity here
and i don't think that they gave the
full support behind it
but they're gonna have to take away from
this because you're pulling resources
from
where i need you to be strongest because
they cannot have
uh what you're calling no blade can't
beat can't you cannot
see this i got it i got to shout my home
girl develop delilah she's making a
point and i'm trying to say
the developer chooses what to and
clearly they are choosing
they to focus on hellblade and their own
product like we keep blaming microsoft
and my thing is bro
when they got higher they got the bag
right microsoft didn't have to say they
saw
they saw ninja theory they saw hellblade
too they saw project bar they were hyped
about that
they weren't hype about what you got but
they still allowed them to make it right
at that point the responsibility in my
opinion right goes on a developer
to support their platform you can't get
mad at microsoft microsoft
allows you to even put that out so
that's why i was like we got to stop all
this old
microsoft would have did this and
microsoft would they chose to say nah
this ain't it
yeah now we're going over the hellblade
that's that's what i just preferred them
not to even let the leading edge come
out if they weren't going to support it
but that's
that's the passing process microsoft for
being kind and saying okay
you can put it out you don't put out a
product that you literally don't really
delegate too many resources to that you
pretty much know you're going to shut
down
you get your fans liking the game but he
was like yeah
as well you have relationships you've
just acquired the studio you don't want
to have
bad will between you thank you thank you
yeah
you're right and and to delilah and cogs
point
the developer that's the developer it
all it all falls down to
for what you do with the clay when you
get it are you going to mold it into
something phenomenal
or or are you just going to you know
like sit there and twirl on it
so it's it's up to the people who has
the clay and who has the ability to mold
it but
you know i think we beat yeah
hold on a second we got a
aka best size finance with the six
dollar super chat cog it gets crazy the
more you play stick with it he's talking
about
the medium yes yes and we have the
living flame with the two dollar super
chat ninja theory already pulled out in
july they hide
okay we have the rubber knob with the
five dollars
morning lads i'm a bit late to the show
big shout out to mods gaming been
following you for a while now
the bushes be blooming this year hashtag
plant food
and then shout out to atl put the crest
in the chat for the newest member of the
realm
shout out to atl absolute atl
then we got aerodynamics for the five
dollar super chat wait attic played an
hour of the medium and called the trash
but won't let no one else like not like
bleeding ass
oh he gonna start up now like you're not
liking
right i'm not gonna argue with some
idiot
like you completely took what i said and
you you completely twisted that to your
knowledge like
nah that wasn't even what the argument
is about the argument is i felt like
they didn't
support enough that would have nothing
to do with other people playing the game
get them out of it get them oh yeah
stitch with the two dollars if we chat
microsoft to bleeding heads
bae
[Laughter]
we good what else i think we're good all
right we gotta go
this is crazy long jesus guys believe it
all right
new i o people with the recent reveal of
microsoft uh
q2 earnings call regarding the positive
health of the xbox division
which has you the most excited for the
future of the platform
king's dancing again choices
18 million game pass subscribers
b overall gaming revenue increase
c more studio acquisitions or d
i don't care what y'all say they still
got to recoup that but testimony
oh god shout out to although that will
go
up on twitter later on lord gasps of
game on daily and lord miles of lords of
gaming.net
my people lord guys where can i find
people find you what you got going on
sir
um you can find me a game on daily.com
game on dailies our
video channel if you're a content
creator you can submit stuff down there
cognito you asked me a shameful question
why is not a lot
the the iron lord stuff on the website
it's because we
it's for the content creators to submit
content we've done something we
submitted
the lead has been bent
[Laughter]
i know it's all these other podcasts but
you don't put mine in there i'm like
you clearly don't listen
we didn't know we thought y'all was vip
thank you so much for having me this has
been the i mean a few hours but i've
just been sitting here listening and
loving the chat man i knew it was going
to be fun and effortless
and you guys are you guys stand out as
one of the best at the best for a reason
so i'm
absolutely had so much fun i was looking
forward to it and i said
cog i'll cancel whatever that was sunday
that was love man thank you for pulling
up man i know like i said we were
talking for a while
some last minute things scheduled
happened with me but the fact he was
still able to pull up and i'm like yes
you know say because i don't want to
wait so long it's like now we're getting
so the schedule's getting crazy it's
hard to get people
or when i want them more you know what
i'm saying but i salute to the addict
for that as well but salute to you
salute to a so we got to get him on i
love what you guys are doing soon to the
entire team please support these guys
game on daily and then go live is
saturdays or at
what time ap dmt a time that king david
cannot
and do what i was trying to explain to
you i said uh saturdays is available
okay they're available now yeah i told
you that see
see you didn't submit your application
right you didn't listen god
i didn't even listen i told you i said
when you're going to have me on
saturdays is good
he's good that's that's me that massive
smile on my face
i just need i want to see aces reactions
to king that's i'm dying to see that
no he was talking we talked how long we
talked for two hours
in that chat trying to get it uh to get
the show started
and it just wasn't happening and then
after that you know he had an
unfortunate death in his family i do
again you know um we tried to do it
again and then it's just been like that
but
mods know mods called me i've met all
the time
poland fighting this fact man that's
fine
beautiful transition louisville's has
been a minute since you've been in the
room man thank you for pulling up man
always a pleasure
super appreciative of what you do and uh
where can the five people find you what
you got going on
yeah well thanks a lot for the invite
always a pleasure to be here and talk
you know all these tokens yeah um you
can find me on youtube
mods gaming or twitter
mods gaming pl and uh yeah i mean
doing daily videos you know whatever i
feel like
talking about basically right so there's
a lot of stuff you know basically going
on right now
in the news you haven't only found this
page
like that damn
[Music]
[Music]
if you don't know some of the best tech
articles you know on loads of gaming.net
by my man mods he always comes through
educating us on the vrs against tactics
thank you brother because it was really
apparent when i was seeing what you were
talking about and i really appreciate
your contribution always a pleasure
working with you
and uh yeah also the channel what about
you about your show your podcast promote
brother what you got going on
you still doing the podcast no i mean
not
not now because my work is crazy right
now
i know a couple of people actually left
my team now
there's only me and another guy you know
basically doing
four you know four people work basically
so
some kind of stuff so until they hire
somebody you know
i'm i'll you know so yeah no podcast for
them for now but youth are still making
the videos man you're still doing
putting out consistent content yeah but
that
you know i dig i you know degraded my
quality a little bit because i don't
really have time for editing and stuff
so
nice and nice when i saw your video i
thought the quality was fantastic
and the level of information was always
spot on to me i i don't know
i when i see it pop up i have my
notifications i sit down i'll watch
finish put my liking probably don't
comment at the bottom when i'm watching
you i'm watching
i appreciate appreciate i mean it's all
in my head so whenever i talk
i just i like like stuck from my heart
or
you know my head you know in terms of
information yeah but
you know i used to do like you know
editing and stuff but it takes more time
and i still want to play our games a
little bit here and there so yeah
hopefully
it will do for now life comes first
brother we will
wait your return in full capacity when
things slow down but salute always
pulling up and always coming through
when i asked you i appreciate it brother
no doubt lord addict very spicy today
where can the fine people find you
what's going on so are we are we
are we still friends are we still
digital not upset or anything
you know the digitary obsidian thing is
always fun continue the first thing i
want to say is uh
i apologize to the individual i called
an idiot thank you sir that was very big
of you
yeah i shouldn't have done that i
thought after i said that i was like man
i'm gonna give him five dollars
i meant to say something else but idiot
came to mind first like
look like the the the point is is
that what you said wasn't the argument
that's where i bit the point but i
should not have called you niggy
uh second off you know we we did have a
most generous
viewer which would be horrible this is
the first thing i call the idiot but
but uh he i don't even it's uh a
k w erichus williams is that what his
name is
um correct pronunciation
he was uh most generous uh with the the
realm he wants to
give back to the realm and he has gave
us a code for
for um hitman three so i'm gonna put
that in the platform oh fantastic
it's it's on xbox i see somebody about
to get that hitman three for staying to
the end
i'm gonna i'm gonna it's either xbox or
steam i don't know
so i'm gonna put that in the chat now
appreciate everyone for coming through
i got it already thanks i mean it was
kind of impossible because i literally
just put it in there
and i literally just took it i got bots
though uh and you know uh kravik is
right uh
you will find me not playing uh bleeding
edge because they're not supporting you
i mean i i didn't even really play much
to start out with
the whole point i was saying is i just
felt like they didn't support it enough
giving it a year to flourish isn't
really a long time that's besides the
fact
uh we'll see you guys next sorry huh no
i think he's in here akw it's for xbox
yeah i think that's a kizi in there
shout out to you brother
and uh he had a great birthday on
tuesday salute yeah i'm saying continue
i just want to shout him out i think
that's him
definitely uh shout out to uh akw that's
what i'm going to pronounce you for now
on
uh he was definitely being generous and
uh you know
we got we got some good guests come up
for you guys man we definitely do
i've been uh emailing one today during
the podcast
uh so hopefully we can talk about this
is cooking right now he's cooking right
now
i appreciate it from coming through
mm-hmm and i will see you next week
no doubt lord sob we're gonna find
people find you sir
yeah first off big shout out to guys and
get the team a game on daily for coming
through
this is really my first interaction with
you really uh but i have followed
the site and stuff like that and and you
guys do amazing work so so
thank you for coming through brother
really appreciate it and of course those
lord mods
always a pleasure to have you here man
yes um and again once again apologies on
my part i will be back on camera next
week so no no no worries
our numbers our female numbers are down
they're down they're down to pass
together
but know that you guys can find me on
twitter lawsomeiop
and bx sovereign on ps uh psn and uh
xbox live that's about it i will try to
finish the medium at some point this
week
no doubt you already know and the king
himself
super spicy with a lot of uh disclaimers
we had to put on his viewpoints
today but uh just to be clear
we're going to find people find you what
else you have going on sir
give a shout out to guys yes so you'll
see me on game one daily soon
i love to hear your rich history and
your realness
when it comes to it because you know we
have uh what is it first world problems
and
third world problems which was really
serious so and the fact that you found
time to game and the ability
to uh have to bend the knee to nintendo
at an early age
because he had to generate
now you're playing with power
i will be on i will be on
txr tonight so keep that in mind no
doubt so
power it does matter
but you know uh definitely uh
he was my first uh shipment
international shipment
yes uh of uh merch and it was
i was i couldn't like when i went to the
post office and i'm sending it out
because this is when i was doing it
personally
and i went to the post office and i was
sending it out and she was like uh
i had to declare customs and stuff like
that i was like wow this
is crazy and the lady behind the thing
was like you have people
in poland obviously now
listen the shipping was more than the
shirt
damn i appreciate that no it wasn't
yeah i really didn't care because
you represent all that is uh wonderful
in this community facts
literally you know um so we do uh
champion your success and
and you know push you you know forward
with everything that you do no matter
what so
that's what when you call i'm there no
matter what um
all right so everybody that came out and
saw my broken statue
i mean it broke my heart when it
happened but i understand the risk
reward type of thing
uh when i'm doing live unboxings and
live unboxing saturdays is the thing
uh that's on dc access darth castle x if
you don't know don't go to the music
channel i won't be there uh but
darth castle x which i do on friday
nights at 9 00 p.m
uh we talk statues we we talk uh
industry stuff we we talk a lot of stuff
it's fun
it's a little bit more mature than you
know uh iop as far as language
goes so you see a whole different king
uh when you're there and you get a
chance to you know be in a different
kind of uh
setting um and i
i just love doing the podcast with you
guys i swear this is so much fun
doing it and talking numbers and doing
stuff that we normally would do on a
saturday
just hang out and just to make sure that
we keep that cohesive net together
it brings me joy and i'm enthusiastic
every saturday night
looking forward to sunday mornings to be
honest with you afternoon salute man
again solve you want to get that chat i
think
yeah qti grizzly with the five dollar
super chat great podcast thank you
brother appreciate it
yeah man like i said king said it best
man love doing this man again salute the
guys that was
amazing love hearing the history love
hearing the stories
and things of what people go through as
well as their journey as a consecrator
that was super dope
man yo you had me thinking i was like yo
pakistan was real
it was reals that i learned a lot today
man salute to you man saluta is a salute
to the team
love what you guys are doing keep up the
good work and of course mine's in the
building
always love you already know how i do
how we do
and uh yeah man again launching
gaming.net thank you guys for supporting
and saying we got the medium review up
and all that good stuff
saw attic and stuff yo we got a lot of
fun stuff planned
the next couple of months buckle up
buckle up we got some
we got some sticks cooking they're
cooking co-hosts is working right now
he's doing this thing he's very humble
but we got things going
anyway look enjoy your sunday we've been
rambling i'm gonna leave y'all and until
next week peace
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
you